What's better than a well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribby you ordered without even leaving the kitty pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. When you're with Amex Platinum, you get access to exclusive dining experiences and an annual travel credit.
有什么比在烧烤架上滋滋作响、大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排更棒的呢？那就是由Instacart购物者精心挑选并送到您家门口的、大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排。您甚至不需要离开儿童戏水池就能订购到大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排。无论您的夏天需要什么杂货，Instacart都能满足您。下载Instacart应用程序，享受前三单免运费优惠。服务费、除外条款和条款适用。Instacart，超额交付的杂货。当您使用美国运通白金卡时，您可以获得独家餐饮体验和年度旅行积分。
So the best tapas in town might be in a new town altogether. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at Amex.ca. Hello, everyone, and welcome to your second drink of safety training. Oh, this is such a good one. This is the one with Michael and Dwight throwing all the watermelons off the roof. Yes, and as you will hear in our breakdown, this episode marked the one-year anniversary of Office Ladies.
所以城里最好的塔帕斯小吃可能在另一个全新的城镇。这就是美国运通的强大支持。条款和条件适用。在Amex.ca了解更多信息。大家好，欢迎收听你们的第二次安全培训。哦，这一集真是太棒了。这一集里迈克尔和德怀特把所有的西瓜都从屋顶上扔了下来。是的，正如你们在我们的解析中听到的那样，这一集标志着《办公室女士》播出一周年。
I remember because you celebrated it by not doing any fast facts. I know. I was reviewing this episode and that made me laugh so hard. We were just one year into our breakdowns and I was already regretting the fast facts. that you decided to do. She were like, I'm going to do fast facts. Well, this is also the episode where Sam gifted us masks of our own faces. Do you remember this? Of course.
我记得是因为你当时通过不做任何“快速事实”来庆祝它。我知道。我当时在回顾这一集，这让我笑得好厉害。我们才刚开始解析一年，我就已经开始后悔你决定做的“快速事实”了。你当时说，我要做“快速事实”。好吧，这也是山姆送给我们每个人自己脸部面具的那一集。你还记得吗？当然。
I remember. I mean, how can one forget being gifted their own face? Well, I bring it up because Sam, I'll have you know that that was the gift that kept on giving. Oh, no. I was cleaning out my podcasting closet recently, and that mask was peeking out behind some other things that I had stacked up. And it scared the shit out of me. Good, good, good, good. Because please remember that my podcasting closet is the one that I believe is haunted.
我记得。我的意思是，怎么会有人忘记被赠送自己的脸呢？好吧，我提起这件事是因为山姆，我要让你知道，那是一份不断给予的礼物。哦，不。我最近在清理我的播客储藏室，那个面具从我堆放的其他东西后面探了出来。它把我吓坏了。好，好，好，好。因为请记住，我的播客储藏室是我认为闹鬼的那一个。
That's right. So my own hollowed out eyes were peeking at me. And it was very scary. Truly my pleasure. It also freaked out my kids, Sam. Good. Okay, well, should we get started with our extra tidbits for this episode? Yes.
没错。所以我自己空洞的眼睛在盯着我看。这非常可怕。真是我的荣幸。它也吓坏了我的孩子们，山姆。好。好吧，我们应该开始这一集的额外花絮了吗？是的。
I have one right at the top. As you know, Andy is returning from anger management in this episode, and he's asking people to call him Drew. He has a talking head where he explains he is a new man with a new attitude and a new name. Well, the writers had a lot of fun with this. There are a few extra tidbits in the candy bag alts for this talking head, and they really paint a picture of this new persona of Drew. Oh, fun. Here's one. I'm a new man with a new name and a whole lot of techniques for control.
我开头就有一个。如你所知，安迪在这一集中从愤怒管理课程回来，他要求人们叫他德鲁。他有一个谈话头镜头，解释说他是一个有着新态度和新名字的新人。好吧，编剧们在这个点子上玩得很开心。这个谈话头镜头的糖果袋备选方案里有一些额外的花絮，它们真的描绘出了德鲁这个新角色的形象。哦，有趣。这里有一个。我是一个有着新名字和一大堆控制技巧的新人。
the grumpies. Also a new car, Honda Insight. Andy didn't care about fuel efficiency. Drew's seen an inconvenient truth nearly twice. This sort of reminds me of when I'm like prepping for a character because I'll be like, well, you know, I like rock and roll, but my character prefers classical music. You know what it made me think of? What? Do you remember in the 90s? I'm pretty sure it was late 90s, when Garth Brooks, the country singer, just decided to have this whole new persona and he named him Chris Gaines and released an album? No. Come on.
那些坏脾气。还有一辆新车，本田Insight。安迪不在乎燃油效率。德鲁几乎看了两遍《难以忽视的真相》。这让我想起我为角色做准备的时候，因为我会说，嗯，你知道，我喜欢摇滚乐，但我这个角色更喜欢古典音乐。你知道它让我想到了什么吗？什么？你还记得90年代吗？我很确定是90年代末，乡村歌手加斯·布鲁克斯决定拥有一个全新的角色，他给自己起名叫克里斯·盖恩斯并发行了一张专辑？不。得了吧。
It was like, people were like, what? What is happening? Right? His name was Chris Gaines, right? Yep. He was like an emo, Groh, Brooks. Yes, he was. Yes.
当时人们就像，什么？发生了什么？对吧？他的名字叫克里斯·盖恩斯，对吧？是的。他就像一个情绪化的加斯·布鲁克斯。是的，他就是。是的。
This is crazy. You don't remember this one? No. This happened. Oh my gosh. Well, maybe our writers were inspired by that. don't know. But also lady in this cold open when Andy, aka Drew, enters, you and I wondered, why did Andy bring his lunch to work on a plate covered in foil? Right. We went on and on about it.
这太疯狂了。你不记得这个了吗？不。这确实发生了。天哪。好吧，也许我们的编剧受到了启发。不知道。但还有，女士，在这个冷开场里，当安迪，也就是德鲁，进来时，你和我都在想，为什么安迪要用一个盖着锡纸的盘子把午餐带到办公室？对吧。我们对此讨论了很久。
Well, many people, including Lee M. Shaley T. Hannah E. And Megan B. said it was a plate of cookies that Andy brought in to share with everyone. It was a deleted scene. And Angela, you literally share about the cookies later in the episode. Oh, you guys. I clearly did not put that together. Me either. Sorry about it. Sorry. Well, they added that deleted scene to the superfan episode and when I watched it, I was like, yep, that is the plate he carried in earlier. It's a very funny scene and I think we should hear it. Great. When people think of Andy, they think of hate and anger. When people think of Drew, they think of baked goods. Oh my God, these cookies have no flavor.
好吧，很多人，包括李·M、谢莉·T、汉娜·E和梅根·B都说那是安迪带进来和大家分享的一盘饼干。那是一个被删减的场景。安吉拉，你后来在这一集中确实提到了饼干。哦，你们。我显然没把这些联系起来。我也没。对此很抱歉。抱歉。好吧，他们把那个被删减的场景加到了超级粉丝版剧集中，当我看到它时，我就想，没错，那就是他之前带进来的盘子。这是一个非常有趣的场景，我觉得我们应该听听。太棒了。当人们想到安迪时，他们想到的是仇恨和愤怒。当人们想到德鲁时，他们想到的是烘焙食品。天哪，这些饼干一点味道都没有。
How is that possible? That are the worst. Who's this Drew checked? Drew isn't a girl. She's handy. Oh, no. Nobody likes my cookies. I'm so angry.
这怎么可能？这是最糟糕的。这个德鲁是谁？德鲁不是个女孩。她很方便。哦，不。没人喜欢我的饼干。我太生气了。
Oh, when I hit something. Totally kidding, guys. Little device I learned to diffuse tension, be the first to make fun of yourself because if they make fun of you before you do, then you might lose your mind. That's so good. It's so good.
哦，当我打什么东西的时候。完全是在开玩笑，伙计们。我学到的小装置用来化解紧张气氛，第一个拿自己开玩笑，因为如果他们在你之前拿你开玩笑，那你可能会失去理智。这太棒了。这太棒了。
Drew, he connects through baking. He does. Well, there was also a very funny candy bag alt-talking head for this moment after he gives everyone the cookies. There were many. This one was my favorite. I thought I could read it. It says, little friend-making device I learned in anger management.
德鲁，他通过烘焙来建立联系。他确实是。好吧，在他给每个人饼干后的这一刻，还有一个非常有趣的糖果袋备选谈话头镜头。有很多。这个是我的最爱。我想我可以读一下。它说，我在愤怒管理中学到的小型交友装置。
When people laugh, they release endorphins. Endorphins are also what is released during sex. So if you can get people to laugh with you, they will feel as if they're having sex with you. I just had sex with Phyllis, Kelly, Stanley, and Meredith, and it was fantastic. I mean, you know what I would do? I would watch, like, just a stack. of candy bag alts. They're there. We did them. There's footage of just us doing one after the other after the other. That's a bonus feature, Dave Rogers, that I would watch. Yeah, Dave,
当人们笑的时候，他们会释放内啡肽。内啡肽也是性爱过程中释放的东西。所以如果你能让人们和你一起笑，他们会感觉就像在和你发生性关系一样。我刚刚和菲利斯、凯利、斯坦利和梅雷迪思发生了性关系，这太棒了。我的意思是，你知道我会做什么吗？我会看，就像，只是一堆糖果袋备选方案。它们就在那里。我们做了它们。有我们一个接一个地做这些的镜头。戴夫·罗杰斯，那是一个我会看的奖励功能。是的，戴夫，
when you're done with the superfan episodes, just do something called the candy bag alts. I bet you someone at Peacock is listening to this and you're going to see it and I just want to mark this occasion as saying it was our idea. Yeah. That's all. We're not going to get anything out of it, but it was our idea. Candy bag alts. Well, overall, this episode is really great. I rewatched the whole thing. And we talk about this in our breakdown,
当你完成超级粉丝版剧集后，就做一些叫糖果袋备选方案的东西。我敢打赌孔雀台有人在听这个，你会看到的，我只是想标记这个场合，说这是我们的主意。是的。就是这样。我们不会从中得到任何东西，但这是我们的主意。糖果袋备选方案。好吧，总的来说，这一集真的很棒。我重看了整集。我们在解析中谈到了这一点，
but it features a lot of the warehouse. Yeah. And in particular, Patrice O'Neill as Lonnie. And lady, I spotted so many breaks, mostly from Mindy and John. Oh, because Patrice was cracking them up. Yes. When Lonnie is going at Michael in the warehouse,
但它有很多仓库的镜头。是的。特别是帕特里斯·奥尼尔饰演的朗尼。女士，我发现了好多笑场，主要是明迪和约翰。哦，因为帕特里斯把他们逗乐了。是的。当朗尼在仓库里针对迈克尔时，
you see John break. He kind of covers it by looking to camera and pretending he's Jim, but it's not Jim, it's John. And when Kelly goes after Lonnie in the bullpen, watch Mindy because you see her do this thing that she would always do where she turns her back to camera and she literally ducks behind BJ. I know. She's done it so many times. We see it every time, Mindy.
你看到约翰笑场了。他通过看向镜头假装他是吉姆来掩盖，但那不是吉姆，那是约翰。当凯利在办公区追着朗尼时，看明迪，因为你看到她做了她总是做的那种事，她背对着镜头，真的躲在BJ后面。我知道。她做过很多次了。我们每次都看到了，明迪。
Well, this episode was a lot of fun to shoot and I hope you enjoy reliving it with us. All right, here's your breakdown of safety training. I'm Jenna Fisher And I'm Angela Kinsey We were on The Office together And we're best friends And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you
好吧，这一集拍摄起来很有趣，我希望你们喜欢和我们一起重温它。好了，这是你们的安全培训解析。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友，现在我们正在为你们制作终极《办公室》重温播客。
Each week we will break down an episode of the office And give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you We're the office ladies Hi everybody Hey you guys Welcome to safety training Yeah
每周我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你们的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。大家好，嘿，你们好，欢迎来到安全培训。是的。
It is season three episode 19 written by B.J. Novak and directed by Harold Ramos. Yes. And Jenna, I mean, I'm going to talk about this as we go. But on the DVD commentary for this episode, there is BJ, Mindy, and Harold Ramos. And it was so wonderful. Gosh. Yeah. Oh, I'm going to go listen to that. I bet that was amazing. It's a great one. It really is. And I'm going to sprinkle in some little nuggets from it. All right. I love it. Let's start with a summary. It is safety. training day in the office. Michael and Dwight are on a mission to illuminate the dangers of the workplace. Meanwhile, Andy returns to the office after his five weeks of anger management training and he is determined to make a fresh start with all of the Dunder Mifflin employees. It is a dozy, Jenna. I have no fast facts today. What? I have no fast facts. Should I go buy a lottery ticket? Like what's happening in the universe or things are going to be a big shift what's going on first of all i have a big thing we have to acknowledge in lieu of fast facts oh what lady today is the one year birthday of
这是第三季第19集，由B.J.诺瓦克编剧，哈罗德·雷米斯执导。是的。珍娜，我的意思是，我们进行时我会谈到这一点。但在这一集的DVD评论中，有BJ、明迪和哈罗德·雷米斯。这太美妙了。天哪。是的，哦，我要去听那个。我敢打赌那一定很棒。这是一个很棒的剧集。确实如此。我会从中撒入一些小金块。好的。我喜欢。让我们从总结开始。今天是办公室的安全培训日。迈克尔和德怀特肩负着阐明工作场所危险的使命。与此同时，安迪在完成了五周的愤怒管理培训后回到了办公室，他决心与所有邓德·米夫林员工重新开始。这是一个很棒的剧集，珍娜。我今天没有快速事实。什么？我没有快速事实。我应该去买张彩票吗？就像宇宙中发生了什么，或者事情将会有巨大的转变，到底发生了什么？首先，我有一件大事，我们必须在没有快速事实的情况下承认。哦，什么，女士，今天是《办公室女士》的一周年生日。
office ladies get out yes yes lady our very first episode aired one year ago this week oh my god how i i'm so bad about putting things in calendars. This is a big deal. This is our one-year birthday. It's our one-year birthday. Happy birthday to us office ladies, boss ladies, podcast.
《办公室女士》，出来吧。是的，是的，女士，我们的第一集是在一年前的这一周播出的。天哪，我，我真不擅长把事情记在日历上。这是一件大事。这是我们的一周年生日。这是我们的一周年生日。祝我们《办公室女士》、老板女士、播客生日快乐。
Oh my gosh. And you guys, thank you for being part of our office ladies' journey for one whole year. Yes. Oh, wait. Yes.
天哪。伙计们，感谢你们参与我们《办公室女士》整整一年的旅程。是的。哦，等等。是的。
Sam is tapping on the glass. Sam. I know why. Yes. I wanted to say congratulations for a year. I got you guys these about a year ago when it came up. up on the podcast and have been waiting patiently for a reason for you guys to open them. So enjoy.
山姆在敲玻璃。山姆。我知道为什么。是的，我想说祝贺你们一周年。大约一年前，当它在播客上出现时，我给你们买了这些，并一直耐心地等待你们打开它们的理由。所以享受吧。
So, Angela, we should tell people you're in the studio. Yes. And Sam just handed you a wrapped gift. Yes. I got one at my house. I'm holding mine. Okay, so we're going to open it together at the same time. Open it together. Sam, here we go. I cannot believe you bought this a year ago. It is in. What is it? Well, it's in some Christmas wrapping paper, which I like. I do too. It's got little dogs and sweaters and things. Angela, congrats on one full. year of office ladies. Aw, Sam. Oh, my God.
所以，安吉拉，我们应该告诉大家你在演播室里。是的。山姆刚刚递给你一份包装好的礼物。是的。我在家里也收到了一个。我拿着我的。好的，所以我们要同时打开它。一起打开它。山姆，我们开始吧。我不敢相信你一年前就买了它。它在。它是什么？好吧，它用了一些圣诞包装纸，我喜欢。我也喜欢。上面有穿着毛衣的小狗之类的东西。安吉拉，祝贺《办公室女士》满一周年。噢，山姆。天哪。
Oh, my God. This is so disturbing. No. Sam. Oh, my God. Sam. Sam. Where did you find these?
天哪。这太令人不安了。不。山姆。天哪。山姆。山姆。你在哪里找到这些的？
You guys, it's our face as a mask. Amazon, there's now 14 available of each. Oh, my Lord. Because you bought one. Oh, my gosh. I guess I have to poke out the eyes. Yeah, in a very creepy way, you have to poke the eyes out to wear them.
伙计们，这是我们脸的面具。亚马逊上，现在每种还有14个。哦，我的天。因为你买了一个。天哪。我想我得把眼睛戳出来。是的，以一种非常令人毛骨悚然的方式，你必须把眼睛戳出来才能戴上它们。
Oh, I don't want to poke my eyes out. Oh, I have to. I just, I just poked my own eyes out. Oh, you did. Okay. I just poked my own eyes out. It was really creepy. Oh, yeah.
哦，我不想把我的眼睛戳出来。哦，我必须。我刚刚，我刚刚把自己的眼睛戳出来了。哦，你做了。好的。我刚刚把自己的眼睛戳出来了。这真的很诡异。哦，是的。
Are you smiling behind your mask, Angela? I am smiling, but I know, you can't tell. Thank you, Sam. Oh, my gosh, Sam. I love it so much. Well, congrats on a year, guys. Wow. Oh, thank you.
你在面具后面笑吗，安吉拉？我在笑，但我知道，你看不出来。谢谢你，山姆。天哪，山姆。我太喜欢它了。好吧，祝贺一周年，伙计们。哇。哦，谢谢。
Oh, my gosh. That was so fun. Well, that, I know it wasn't a fast fact, but that was pretty great. Yeah. That was like an office lady's big fact. Yeah. Well, I thought that since it's our birthday, in lieu of fast facts, I thought we could just go to our mailbag and answer some frequently asked questions this week. Oh, I love that.
天哪。那太有趣了。好吧，那个，我知道那不是快速事实，但那真的很棒。是的。那就像一个《办公室女士》的大事实。是的。好吧，我想既然是我们的生日，代替快速事实，我想我们可以看看我们的邮件袋，回答一些本周的常见问题。哦，我喜欢那个。
Here is a fan question from Eve and Maria Barbic. They said, each time there is a conference room meeting, is everyone given an assigned seat or can you sit where you want? We were always given an assigned seat. We would walk into the conference room and they would usually have a little sticky note on each chair. with our name on it. Yeah. And we knew that was our spot. Because they would plan it out.
这是一个来自伊芙和玛丽亚·巴比克的粉丝问题。她们说，每次有会议室会议时，每个人都有指定的座位，还是可以随心所欲地坐？我们总是被指定座位。我们会走进会议室，他们通常会在每把椅子上贴一张小便利贴，上面写着我们的名字。是的。我们知道那是我们的位置。因为他们会提前计划好。
They would plan the camera blocking and the camera angles and how they were going to catch all of our reactions according to who had dialogue and who didn't. Yeah. So they planned all that out before we even walked in the room. Yeah. Sometimes someone's dialogue would affect someone else and you would need to see their reaction immediately after the line of dialogue. So they had that all mapped out.
他们会计划摄像机的遮挡和拍摄角度，以及他们将如何根据谁有台词谁没有来捕捉我们所有的反应。是的。所以他们在我们走进房间之前就计划好了一切。是的。有时某人的台词会影响另一个人，你需要看到他们在台词后的即时反应。所以他们把这些都规划好了。
And sometimes, if you were really big and pregnant, you were in the back row, just going to say. Yes. So we could hide that big old belly. That's right. We're getting close to that, Ange. To my belly? Yeah. That's next season.
有时，如果你怀孕了，肚子很大，你就会坐在后排，我只是想说。是的。这样我们就可以藏起那个大肚子。没错。我们快要到那个阶段了，安吉。到我的肚子？是的。那是下一季的事。
I know. That's going to be crazy for me. I can't wait to hear those stories. I'm just going to probably drive you guys all crazy because I'm going to be like, and this one, Isabel was really kicking. I can't wait. I can't wait. We're going to get it all down on record. What else you got? All right. This question comes from, Raisha Patterson. Can you explain the decision of the audience not hearing the questions posed by the documentary crew? So like in our talking heads, right? Yeah. She asked, did Greg Daniels make this decision or was this taken from the BBC version?
我知道。那对我来说会很疯狂。我迫不及待想听那些故事了。我可能会让你们所有人发疯，因为我会说，还有这个，伊莎贝尔真的在踢我。我等不及了。我等不及了。我们要把这一切都记录下来。你还有什么？好的。这个问题来自雷莎·帕特森。你能解释一下为什么观众听不到纪录片摄制组提出的问题吗？就像在我们的谈话头镜头里，对吧？是的。她问，这是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的决定，还是从BBC版本中借鉴的？
Well, I mean, I have my thoughts. My thoughts are usually in a documentary. The camera crew, wants to disappear. They want to really capture people's lives, and they try not to, like, interfere too much. And so I would guess, and I think you probably have the answer, that they wanted it that way. They wanted it to really feel like a documentary. Yeah, I reached out to Greg, Ang, and you are exactly right. He said they made the decision because he felt like the audience would be more invested and more connected to our characters if you didn't hear anyone asking the questions, if your mind wasn't thinking about this crew of people filming them. Yeah. But he said, they did wonder about this all the time. They wondered about what are the circumstances when they might reveal someone from the crew.
好吧，我的意思是，我有我的想法。我的想法通常是，在纪录片中，摄制组想要消失。他们真的想捕捉人们的生活，他们尽量不去干扰太多。所以我猜，我想你可能知道答案，他们想要那样。他们想让它真正感觉像一部纪录片。是的，我联系了格雷格，安吉，你说得完全正确。他说他们做出这个决定是因为他觉得如果观众听不到任何人提问，如果你的大脑没有在思考这群拍摄他们的人，观众会更投入，与我们的角色联系更紧密。是的。但他说，他们确实一直都在想这个问题。他们想知道在什么情况下他们可能会揭露摄制组的人。
And I remember, at least on set, Angela, I don't know if you remember this, but there was this big debate about in the final season or ever, if we reveal who the documentarian is, who's been making this, who should it be? And I remember the cast saying that it should either be Greg Daniels or Ken Quappas. Do you remember this conversation? I do. I do. And I remember I wanted that. I wanted to see the camera crew. But also, Jenna, I don't know what it's like for you when you watch actual documentaries. I love them. And if I ever hear the voice of like the documentarian, like off camera, I'm, I'm instantly fascinated. I'm like, okay, I want to see this person. Yeah, you want to see a shot of their face. Yeah. Right? You're like,
我记得，至少在片场，安吉拉，我不知道你是否记得，但当时有一个大争论，在最后一季或者任何时候，如果我们揭露谁是纪录片制作者，谁一直在制作这个，那应该是谁？我记得演员们说那应该是格雷格·丹尼尔斯或肯·夸帕斯。你记得这个对话吗？我记得。我记得。我记得我想要那个。我想看到摄制组。但珍娜，我不知道当你观看真正的纪录片时是什么感觉。我喜欢它们。如果我听到纪录片制作者的声音，就像在镜头外，我会立刻着迷。我会想，好吧，我想看到这个人。是的，你想看到他们脸部的镜头。对吧？你会想，
I've heard a voice. Yeah. Well, Greg told me that there was also some debate that maybe it should be Randall Einhorn or Ricky Jervais. Oh. That like at the very end, it would be revealed that Ricky Jervase was our documentarian. I would like to go one step further and say, what if it was David Brent? Oh, no. What if David Brent had come from the UK to make a documentary in America like his own? Well, I guess there was a problem with this idea because Greg told me that there are a few times that you do hear the voice for the documentarian. And do you know whose voice it is?
我听到了一个声音。是的。好吧，格雷格告诉我，还有一些争论，也许应该是兰德尔·艾因霍恩或瑞奇·热维斯。哦。就像在最后，会揭露瑞奇·热维斯是我们的纪录片制作者。我想更进一步说，如果那是大卫·布伦特会怎样？哦，不。如果大卫·布伦特从英国来到美国制作一部像他自己那样的纪录片会怎样？好吧，我想这个想法有个问题，因为格雷格告诉我，有几次你确实听到了纪录片制作者的声音。你知道那是谁的声音吗？
Ken Quappas. Dave Rogers. Oh, no way. Right? And when Greg told me that, I couldn't even think of any times that we heard the voice. Did he loop it in? Like, when did he? Yeah.
肯·夸帕斯。戴夫·罗杰斯。哦，不会吧。对吧？当格雷格告诉我时，我甚至想不出我们听到那个声音的任何时候。他把它循环进去了吗？就像，他什么时候？是的。
And I don't know why or when. So we haven't gotten to it, right? Like, we haven't heard a documentarian yet so far. Yeah. So it must be coming up. We're going to have to track it. Oh, wow. I want to track that.
我不知道为什么或什么时候。所以我们还没到那儿，对吧？就像，到目前为止我们还没听到纪录片制作者的声音。是的。所以它一定快到了。我们必须追踪它。哦，哇。我想追踪那个。
These are good. These are good questions. I thought so, too. All right. Are you ready for another one? Yeah. All right. This question, we got a lot.
这些很好。这些都是好问题。我也这么认为。好的。你准备好迎接下一个了吗？是的。好的。这个问题，我们收到了很多。
This was definitely a most frequently asked. Okay. We got this question from Julianne K., Luke D., Cade Smith, Alana Boylan, and two Emmylies. Okay. The first one is Emily Howard, and the second is my own sister, Emily. You texted me this question. She has been catching up on our podcast, Angela, and it's so funny because I'll just suddenly get a text where she's like,
这绝对是最常被问到的问题。好的。我们收到了朱莉安·K、卢克·D、凯德·史密斯、阿拉娜·博伊兰和两个艾米莉的问题。好的。第一个是艾米莉·霍华德，第二个是我自己的妹妹艾米莉。你给我发短信问了这个问题。她一直在补我们的播客，安吉拉，这太搞笑了，因为我会突然收到一条短信，她说，
Oh, my God, you told people I threw up in Ellie's bushes? I know. I know. I know. And I'm like, oh, yeah, you're just catching that. Yeah. That happened a while ago. Yeah.
天哪，你告诉别人我在艾莉的灌木丛里呕吐了？我知道。我知道。我知道。我说，哦，是的，你才刚看到那集。是的。那发生在很久以前。是的。
My sister, Janet, listens. And so does my stepson, Jack. And remember when we did laundry and betrayal? Yeah. Jack came out of his bedroom with his headphones on and was like, Angela. I was like, I'm sorry. Our kids don't hear us talk like that. What did Emily ask?
我的妹妹珍妮特在听。我的继子杰克也在听。还记得我们做《洗衣与背叛》那集吗？是的。杰克戴着耳机从卧室出来说，安吉拉。我说，我很抱歉。我们的孩子没听过我们那样说话。艾米莉问了什么？
Okay, they all want to know, why do we have multiple directors on the show instead of just one? So he can prep the other one, right? I mean... So I actually called my sister because I was like, I don't know how to put this in a text. And I explained it like this. I said, you know, it takes us one week to shoot an episode, but the director works the week prior preparing it and the week after editing it. So the director's job is three weeks long. So you couldn't have someone direct every single episode.
好的，他们都想知道，为什么我们节目里有多个导演而不是只有一个？这样他就可以准备另一个，对吧？我的意思是……所以我实际上给我妹妹打了电话，因为我说，我不知道怎么在短信里表达。我是这样解释的。我说，你知道，我们拍一集需要一周时间，但导演在前一周准备，后一周剪辑。所以导演的工作是三周长。所以你不可能让一个人导演每一集。
It would just be impossible. But she was like, well, I don't know because sometimes I watch these streaming shows and they have the same director the whole time. And I'm like, yeah, that's because on those streaming shows, a lot of times they've written, it's a short number of scripts. It's six scripts or eight scripts. And they write them all. And then they kind of shoot them like one big long movie. That's true. And they do all their prep beforehand and they do all their editing after.
那是不可能的。但她说，嗯，我不知道，因为有时我看这些流媒体节目，他们全程都是同一个导演。我说，是的，那是因为在那些流媒体节目中，很多时候他们写的是少量的剧本。是六个剧本或八个剧本。他们把它们都写出来。然后他们就像拍一部长电影一样拍摄它们。那是真的。他们提前做好所有准备，之后做所有剪辑。
And they'll shoot out of order, too. They'll, like a movie, they will wrap out locations. So it will be like, we're going to shoot every single scene we have at the high school this week. Yeah. And next week, we're going to shoot every scene at the house. And they shoot like a movie. But on our show, we shot each episode like its own little mini movie. So that's why.
他们也会乱序拍摄。他们会像电影一样，完成一个地点的拍摄。所以就像，我们这周要拍我们在高中所有的场景。是的。下周，我们要拍在房子里所有的场景。他们像拍电影一样拍摄。但在我们的节目中，我们把每一集都拍得像它自己的小电影。所以这就是原因。
And we also did like 24 instead of 6. Exactly. Yeah. And they would be writing while we were shooting. So, yeah, that's why we have one director per episode and they switch. Yeah. So now, Angela, this one comes to you. This is from Christina Kuzland. Okay. And she said this. Angela, can you say something in Indonesian on your podcast? Because my daughter, Alana, is studying the language in school. She is a big fan of the show and thought it was so cool that the person who played her favorite office character had grown up in Indonesia. All right, Alani, how about we say hi, how are you? I'm fine. Thank you. Okay, Jenna, we'll do it together. Yes. So, how are you? Is Apakabar? Aba Kabar. Kabar. Kabar. Kabar. Khabar. Thank you, thank you. That's just a little simple phrase, but I mean, I loved growing up in Indonesia. I had such a wonderful childhood there, and I have very fond memories. So thank you for
而且我们做了24集而不是6集。完全正确。是的。而且我们在拍摄时他们还在写剧本。所以，是的，这就是为什么我们每集有一个导演，而且他们会轮换。是的。所以现在，安吉拉，这个问题是给你的。这是来自克里斯蒂娜·库兹兰。好的。她说这个。安吉拉，你能在你的播客上用印尼语说点什么吗？因为我的女儿阿拉娜正在学校学习这门语言。她是这个节目的忠实粉丝，觉得扮演她最喜欢的办公室角色的人在印尼长大真是太酷了。好的，阿拉尼，我们说你好，你好吗？我很好。谢谢。好的，珍娜，我们一起做。是的。那么，你好吗？是Apa kabar？Aba Kabar。Kabar。Kabar。Kabar。Khabar。谢谢，谢谢。那只是一个简单的小短语，但我的意思是，我喜欢在印尼长大。我在那里度过了一个非常美好的童年，我有非常美好的回忆。所以谢谢你
asking that question. I get really excited if I ever run into anyone that can speak Indonesian. Like years ago, I was at the mall and there was a couple over by a bunch of shoes and they were talking about the shoes. And the man said, wadu Mahalsakali. And what he was saying was like, these were really expensive. And I got so excited. And I was like, oh, under vagina, Bahasa Indonesia. Like, I was like, you guys speak Indonesian. And they looked at me like, what? And then we spoke in Tunisian. I get, I really geek out. I get really excited.
问那个问题。如果我遇到任何会说印尼语的人，我会非常兴奋。就像几年前，我在商场，有一对夫妇在鞋子旁边，他们在谈论鞋子。那个男人说，wadu mahal sekali。他的意思是，这些真的很贵。我太兴奋了。我说，哦，Anda bicara Bahasa Indonesia。就像，我说，你们会说印尼语。他们看着我像，什么？然后我们用印尼语交谈。我真的，我真的很着迷。我真的很兴奋。
Angela, you speak three languages because you also speak Spanish. Um, poco. Yo, I, I understand more than I can speak it. See? I feel like I understand it better than I can speak it. Yeah. But I really admire this about you. I wish that I spoke another language fluently and I don't.
安吉拉，你会说三种语言，因为你也会说西班牙语。嗯，poco。Yo，我，我理解的比我会说的多。Si？我觉得我理解的比我会说的更好。是的。但我真的很钦佩你这一点。我希望我能流利地说另一种语言，但我不会。
Well, you know, during this time, I've been doing du lingo. I love du lingo. Lingo. Which language? I've been just brushing up on Spanish because I feel like I could be close, you know, closer to being fluent in Spanish. And Indonesian is great, but I don't get a lot of chance to use it here. Yeah. Yeah. I don't get a lot of opportunities to speak it. Well, thank you to Christina and Alani. We really liked that question. Thanks, guys. Tremakasi. So, Ann, you know that we get a lot of mail from people telling us how much the office and this podcast is helping to get them through tough times.
好吧，你知道，在这段时间里，我一直在用多邻国。我喜欢多邻国。Lingo。哪种语言？我一直在复习西班牙语，因为我觉得我可以更接近，你知道，更接近流利地说西班牙语。印尼语很棒，但我在这里没有太多机会使用它。是的。是的。我没有太多机会说它。好吧，谢谢克里斯蒂娜和阿拉尼。我们真的很喜欢那个问题。谢谢，伙计们。Terima kasih。所以，安，你知道我们收到很多人的来信，告诉我们《办公室》和这个播客在帮助他们度过困难时期。
Yeah, and your letters and emails mean a lot to us, and we thought we would share a few here today. Yes. So, John Petrie wrote in to tell us just this beautiful email about how he and his daughter, Kayla, have bonded while listening to Office Ladies and what that has meant to him. And, John, your letter really touched our heart. Aw. Well, Luke Foote wrote in about his daughter, Sophia, who is having some health issues, and she's a big fan of the show, and we wanted to give her a little shout-out. Hi, Sophia. Hi, Sophia.
是的，你们的信件和电子邮件对我们意义重大，我们想今天在这里分享一些。是的。所以，约翰·佩特里写信告诉我们这封美丽的邮件，关于他和他的女儿凯拉在听《办公室女士》时是如何建立联系的，以及这对他的意义。约翰，你的信真的触动了我们的心。噢。好吧，卢克·福特写信谈到了他的女儿索菲亚，她有一些健康问题，她是这个节目的忠实粉丝，我们想给她一个小小的呼喊。嗨，索菲亚。嗨，索菲亚。
We just want to say thanks for listening, and we're so glad you love the show, and we're sending you some big hugs. Yes. And we also want to say hello to Julia in Mount Prospect, Illinois. Julia, we hope that you get better soon so you can get home to your little kiddos. Yeah.
我们只想说谢谢你们的收听，我们很高兴你们喜欢这个节目，我们给你们送上大大的拥抱。是的。我们也想向伊利诺伊州芒特普罗斯佩克特的朱莉娅问好。朱莉娅，我们希望你早日康复，这样你就可以回家陪你的小孩子们了。是的。
And, guys, I know that we've said this before, but we really love doing this podcast each week. It is our absolute pleasure to rewatch this week. you. We love your messages. I just, I feel so grateful to be connected in this way and doing this show has just been a really special thing for us too. I mean, yeah, I get emotional to even talk about what this time and doing this with you, Jenna, and sharing with everyone that's listening in each week and just having a community with all of you. And, um, We just love you guys.
而且，伙计们，我知道我们之前说过，但我们真的很喜欢每周做这个播客。重温这一周绝对是我们的荣幸。你们。我们喜欢你们的信息。我只是，我感到非常感激能以这种方式联系，做这个节目对我们来说也是一件非常特别的事情。我的意思是，是的，谈论这段时间，和你一起做这件事，珍娜，并与每周收听的每个人分享，并与你们所有人建立一个社区，我甚至会情绪化。而且，嗯，我们只是爱你们。
It feeds us as much as it feeds you. Yeah. I mean, I get a lot of messages, Ange, that people tell us like, oh, I'm listening to you while I drive to work. And it really calms me down before my job. Or, you know, I'm listening while I'm home. It's, you know, I'm doing the laundry and I'm listening to you. And it's funny, Anch, because that's when I listen to our episodes, you know, when we get ready to do our edit notes, I fold the laundry and listen to us. too. So I think I know literally what you're talking about. I do the same thing. Oh, lady, I've listened to us while
它滋养我们就像它滋养你们一样。是的。我的意思是，我收到很多信息，安吉，人们告诉我们，哦，我开车去上班时在听你们的节目。它真的让我在工作前平静下来。或者，你知道，我在家时在听。它，你知道，我在洗衣服，我在听你们。这很有趣，安吉，因为那就是我听我们剧集的时候，你知道，当我们准备做剪辑笔记时，我折叠衣服并听我们。也。所以我认为我真的知道你在说什么。我也做同样的事情。哦，女士，我听过我们
picking up dog poop. Oh, boy. I don't. I like have my headphones on listening to us, just like whatever it is I'm doing. But I love to hear everyone's stories so much. And it just, it just all of it warms my heart. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? Okay. And then we will come back with some safety training. All right. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, sometimes we turn to some funny places for support. Maybe a hairdresser, a barista, maybe a random stranger in the bathroom for life advice. But not everyone is a therapist.
捡狗屎。哦，男孩。我不。我戴着耳机听我们，就像我正在做的任何事情一样。但我非常喜欢听每个人的故事。而且它，它所有的一切都温暖了我的心。好吧，听着，我们休息一下好吗？好的。然后我们会回来进行一些安全培训。好的。这个节目由BetterHelp赞助。你知道，有时我们会转向一些有趣的地方寻求支持。也许是理发师，咖啡师，也许是浴室里的随机陌生人寻求生活建议。但并不是每个人都是治疗师。
You can find your right match with BetterHelp. BetterHelp therapists are clinically trained and credentialed. They work according to a strict code of conduct and are fully. licensed in the US. And BetterHelp does the initial matching work for you, so you can focus on your therapy goals. You'll get a short questionnaire that helps identify your needs and preferences, and then they will match you with a licensed therapist. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Find the one with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10
你可以在BetterHelp找到你的合适人选。BetterHelp治疗师经过临床培训和认证。他们按照严格的行为准则工作，并在美国获得完全许可。BetterHelp为你做初步的匹配工作，这样你就可以专注于你的治疗目标。你会得到一份简短的问卷，帮助确定你的需求和偏好，然后他们会为你匹配一位持证治疗师。作为世界上最大的在线治疗提供商，BetterHelp可以提供接触具有多种专业知识的心理健康专业人员的机会。用BetterHelp找到那个合适的人。我们的听众获得10
sent off their first month at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelphelp.com slash office ladies. Hi, I'm Nancy Cartwright. You may know me better as the voice of Bart Simpson. On Simpsons Declassified, we're diving into the mysteries that keep the Simpsons forever young. Have you ever wondered how the Simpsons regularly predicts future events? Who better to ask than the show's creators, performers, and writers? The celebrity guests, Be sure to follow and listen to Simpsons Declassified wherever you get your podcasts. During the Volvo Fall Experience event,
在betterhelp.com/officeladies上享受第一个月的折扣。那是BetterHelphelp.com/officeladies。嗨，我是南希·卡特赖特。你可能更了解我是巴特·辛普森的声音。在《辛普森一家解密》中，我们正在深入研究让辛普森一家永远年轻的谜团。你有没有想过辛普森一家是如何定期预测未来事件的？还有谁比节目的创作者、表演者和编剧更适合问呢？名人嘉宾，一定要在任何你获取播客的地方关注并收听《辛普森一家解密》。在沃尔沃秋季体验活动期间，
discover exceptional offers and thoughtful design that leaves plenty of room for autumn adventures. And see for yourself how Volvo's legendary safety brings peace of mind to every crisp morning commute. This September, leased a 2026 X-E-90 plug-in hybrid from $599 biweekly at 3.9. during the Volvo Fall Experience event.
发现卓越的优惠和体贴的设计，为秋季冒险留下充足的空间。亲眼看看沃尔沃传奇般的安全性如何为每个清爽的早晨通勤带来内心的平静。今年九月，租赁2026款XE90插电式混合动力车，每两周599美元起，利率为3.9%。在沃尔沃秋季体验活动期间。
Conditions supply, visit your local Volvo retailer or go to explorevolvo.com. The twisted tale of Amanda Knox is an eight-episode Hulu Original Limited series that blends gripping pacing with emotional complexity, offering a dramatized look as it revisits the wrongful conviction of Amanda Knox for the tragic murder of Meredith Kircher
条件适用，请访问您当地的沃尔沃零售商或前往explorevolvo.com。阿曼达·诺克斯的扭曲故事是一部八集的Hulu原创限定剧，融合了扣人心弦的节奏和情感复杂性，提供了一个戏剧化的视角，因为它重温了阿曼达·诺克斯因梅雷迪思·克彻的悲惨谋杀而被错误定罪的案件
and the relentless media storm that followed. The twisted tale of, of Amanda Knox is now streaming only on Disney Plus. All right, so we start this episode with Andy coming back into the office. He's back, and he's new and improved. He's going to go by the name Drew, and he walks up to Pam. He's got a box full of stuff. Jenna, two things I need to discuss right out of the gate.
以及随之而来的无情的媒体风暴。阿曼达·诺克斯的扭曲故事现在仅在Disney Plus上播放。好的，所以我们以安迪回到办公室开始这一集。他回来了，他焕然一新。他打算改名叫德鲁，他走到帕姆身边。他拿着一个装满东西的盒子。珍娜，有两件事我需要从一开始就讨论。
All right. Number one, at four seconds. We have a new plant at reception. No. We just had a new plant. It doesn't matter. Pam. Pam throws them out every week, clearly.
好的。第一，在四秒钟时。我们在接待处有一株新植物。不。我们刚有一株新植物。没关系。帕姆。帕姆显然每周都把它们扔掉。
What is her problem? It's even in a new pot. It's a ceramic pot. It's kind of like a rainbow, like trimmed in like a purple. What's happening? I don't know, Angela, but I want to say, you know, there's a lot of things that we've been noticing that then if you deep dive on the internet, you see lots of people have noticed. I have never once seen this plant issue come up.
她有什么问题？它甚至在一个新花盆里。这是一个陶瓷花盆。它有点像彩虹，边缘是紫色的。发生了什么？我不知道，安吉拉，但我想说，你知道，我们注意到了很多事情，如果你在互联网上深入挖掘，你会看到很多人都注意到了。我从来没见过这个植物问题出现过。
This is exclusive to you and this podcast. I know this sounds crazy, but I had this thought that I wanted to screen grab every single plant at front reception and make collage art out of it. Yeah, and then frame it and I'll hang it in my office. Oh, okay, wait. Here's this week's, ready? Oh, this one is in like a rainbow striped pot. I know. It's very festive.
这是你和这个播客独有的。我知道这听起来很疯狂，但我有一个想法，我想截取前台每一株植物的屏幕，并用它制作拼贴艺术。是的，然后把它装裱起来，我会把它挂在我的办公室里。哦，好的，等等。这是本周的，准备好了吗？哦，这个在一个彩虹条纹的花盆里。我知道。它非常喜庆。
I know. You'll never see it again. Say goodbye to it. All right. What was your other thing? Well, my other thing is, you know, Andy slash Drew, his box of stuff, what is wrapped in tinfoil? It looks like a, is it a plate of food? What is it?
我知道。你再也见不到它了。和它说再见吧。好的。你的另一件事是什么？好吧，我的另一件事是，你知道，安迪/德鲁，他的东西盒，什么东西是用锡纸包着的？它看起来像一个，那是盘食物吗？那是什么？
Yes, I saw that as well. And I was like, who brings their lunch in like that? Is that his lunch? Yeah, I don't know. I was very curious about it. You know, when Andy has his talking head and he's sort of explaining that he's going to go by a new name, he's got a new attitude, and he's got a new way to deal with the grumpies. Did you notice how much wall there was in his talking head?
是的，我也看到了。我当时想，谁会那样带午餐？那是他的午餐吗？是的，我不知道。我对此很好奇。你知道，当安迪有他的谈话头镜头，他正在解释他要改一个新名字，他有了一个新态度，他有了一种处理坏脾气的新方法。你注意到他的谈话头镜头里有多少墙了吗？
No, I guess I was... There's like, it's all wall. There's almost no window. And then when it cuts to Dwight's talking head, where he's talking about how he has to shun Andy. Yeah. In Dwight's talking head, it's a lot of window and very little wall. It was just something I noticed. Is it because Dwight has a future at this company, but Andy doesn't? Maybe Andy hit a wall? I don't know. I don't know. There's a lot of wall.
不，我想我当时……那里就像，全是墙。几乎没有窗户。然后当它切到德怀特的谈话头镜头时，他在谈论他必须避开安迪。是的。在德怀特的谈话头镜头里，有很多窗户，墙很少。这只是我注意到的事情。是因为德怀特在这家公司有未来，而安迪没有吗？也许安迪撞墙了？我不知道。我不知道。有很多墙。
That's all I'm saying. Well, I do notice that Andy always, he's like one of these people that has little, little phrases for everything, like his nifty gifties and the grumpies. And a lot of nicknames. Well, we had a fan question from Don Mackley. Okay. Who wrote in to say, there are so many times Andy mentions his old nicknames and they're almost always different. How many nicknames were mentioned over the course of the show? Oh, my Lord.
我只是这么说。好吧，我确实注意到安迪总是，他就像那种对每件事都有小短语的人，比如他的俏皮礼物和坏脾气。还有很多绰号。好吧，我们有一个来自唐·麦克利的粉丝问题。好的。他写信说，安迪提到他旧绰号的次数太多了，而且几乎总是不同的。在节目过程中提到了多少个绰号？哦，我的天。
That's a good question. I looked it up in the show Bible. Okay. And here is what it says. Here they are. Ready? Nard dog, boner champ. King Butt, Ice Man, Puk, Ace, Buzz.
这是一个好问题。我在节目圣经里查过了。好的。这是它说的。它们在这里。准备好了吗？Nard dog，Boner champ。King Butt，Ice Man，Puk，Ace，Buzz。
Those were while he was in college. Okay. And then in this episode, he asked everyone to be called Drew. And in the next episode, he gives himself the nickname Will Do. So these are just nicknames for Andy, for himself. Just Andy. Right, because it's not like his friends. like Broccoli Rob and all those guys.
那些是他上大学时用的。好的。然后在这一集中，他要求每个人叫他德鲁。在下一集里，他给了自己一个绰号Will Do。所以这些只是安迪给自己的绰号。只是安迪。对，因为不像他的朋友。像西兰花罗布和那些家伙。
Yes, that's right. These are just names that Andy has referred to himself as being. Bone or champ? So there you go. Wow. So that's nine. I counted nine. Nine nicknames.
是的，没错。这些只是安迪自称的名字。Boner champ？所以就是这样。哇。所以那是九个。我数了九个。九个绰号。
What were nicknames you had growing up? What about your friends? Just no. They called me Jenna. Oh my gosh. What? Well, let's see. In college.
你小时候有什么绰号？你的朋友呢？只是没有。他们叫我珍娜。天哪。什么？好吧，让我们看看。在大学。
Hambone. Well, that was high school. Hambone. I was also called bones because it was really skinny. Handbone, bones. Then I was in college, my roommate's name was also Angela, so they called me Kinsey. And then that became Kinns, Tiny Kinns. But I had a perm, and I would wear a ponytail kind of like on top of my head.
Hambone。好吧，那是高中。Hambone。我也被称为Bones，因为我真的很瘦。Handbone，Bones。然后我在大学，我室友的名字也叫安吉拉，所以他们叫我Kinsey。然后那变成了Kinns，Tiny Kinns。但我烫了头发，我会把马尾辫扎在头顶上。
So a few people started calling me kush ball. Okay. Cush ball, handbone, bones, tinykins. A lot of nicknames. You're very Andy Askins. I gave myself a nickname when I was on a charity softball team for Children's Mercy. hospital. Please tell me what it is. The Kensinator. Wow. That was on my jersey. Oh my God. I'm Andy. What's happening? I don't know. I mean, people called me Fisher. They called me by my last name. But it was never like,
所以几个人开始叫我Cush ball。好的。Cush ball，Handbone，Bones，Tinykins。很多绰号。你非常像安迪。我在为儿童慈悲医院的慈善垒球队效力时给自己起了一个绰号。请告诉我那是什么。The Kensinator。哇。那在我的球衣上。天哪。我是安迪。发生了什么？我不知道。我的意思是，人们叫我Fisher。他们叫我的姓。但它从来不像，
it never felt like an official nickname. Right. Well, my friend told me once, listen to this. Tell me if this hits you. What? A friend of mine went and did this very intense, like, therapy week at this Therapy Center. Great. Right. This is where you're supposed to like dig in to any of your childhood traumas. Oh, God. And really unpack all your baggage.
它从来没有感觉像一个正式的绰号。对。好吧，我的朋友曾经告诉我，听这个。告诉我这是否击中了你。什么？我的一个朋友去了一个非常强烈的，就像，治疗中心的一周治疗。太棒了。对吧。这就是你应该深入挖掘你童年创伤的地方。哦，上帝。并真正解开你所有的包袱。
Sounds horrible. Right? Super intense. What he told me was that when you get there, you fill out a form and you are asked, what is the nickname that your parents called you when you were a child? And that is the name they refer to you as the entire week. And it's supposed to, I think, try to put you. like back into a space where you'll start unpacking all your baggage.
听起来太可怕了，对吧？非常强烈。他告诉我，当你到达那里时，你需要填一张表格，上面会问你：你小时候父母叫你的昵称是什么？那一周他们就一直用那个名字称呼你。我想，这应该是为了让你回到过去，开始整理你所有的心理包袱。
I don't want to go because I don't want to fill out any forms. I'm done with forms. Well, we know that about you. I don't want to fill out your form. I don't want to do your questionnaire. I'm surprised you have a passport. Because that was some real intense form filling out. I know.
我不想去，因为我不想填任何表格。我受够了表格。好吧，我们了解你这一点。我不想填你的表格。我不想做你的问卷。我很惊讶你竟然有护照。因为那可是非常繁琐的表格填写工作。我知道。
And that I got into college. So many forms. So many forms. They're not for you. I did it when I had to do it. I'm done. I'm done. Yeah.
还有我上大学的时候。那么多表格。那么多表格。它们不适合你。我必须做的时候就做了。我受够了。我受够了。是的。
Okay. This intense therapy place that lost you at forms. Yeah. Too many forms. Pass. Okay. Well, I have a beef with Jim. I think I know what it is.
好吧。这个让你对表格望而却步的强化治疗场所。是的。表格太多了。放弃。好吧。嗯，我和吉姆有点过节。我想我知道是什么了。
Andy is really earnestly doing his process that he went through from anger management. He's trying to turn things around. He tells Jim he's going to go by Drew now. And Jim goes, no, I'm not going to call you that. And I was like, what a jerk. What a jerk. Yeah. Why not?
安迪非常认真地执行着他从愤怒管理课程中学到的流程。他试图改过自新。他告诉吉姆他现在要改名叫德鲁。吉姆却说，不，我不会那样叫你。我当时就觉得，真是个混蛋。真是个混蛋。是的。为什么不呢？
God, what does it cost you to call this guy Drew? He's just messing with him to mess with him. Yeah. Why are you being an instigator with a person who's struggling to, you know, turn over a new leaf? Yeah. There is a runner in the deleted scenes of Andy going through different scenarios with everyone in the office where he's tested. And he keeps being earnest and trying to get through them. Like he brought in cookies and they were really crappy.
天哪，叫这家伙德鲁又不会让你损失什么？他只是为了找茬而找茬。是的。为什么你要去挑衅一个正在努力改过自新的人呢？是的。在删除的片段里有一个连续的桥段，安迪在办公室里和每个人进行不同的情境演练，他受到了考验。他一直保持真诚，试图通过这些考验。比如他带了饼干来，但饼干做得非常糟糕。
And people were talking about how crappy the cookies were. And they were like, oh, who brought them in? And Andy was like, huh, me. But he didn't get mad. He was just like working through it. So, yeah, I thought Jim was a little bit of a jerk right there. I agree. Oh, and Jenna, I want to go back to Dwight's talking head.
大家都在议论饼干有多难吃。他们说，哦，是谁带来的？安迪说，呃，是我。但他没有生气。他只是在努力克服。所以，是的，我觉得吉姆当时有点混蛋。我同意。哦，还有珍娜，我想回到德怀特的访谈片段。
Speaking of forms to fill out about your childhood, what would he have written? He was shunned from ages four to six because he didn't save the excess oil from a tuna can. I mean, he said it's like slapping someone with silence. Yeesh. Yeah. Well, let's get in. to the main plot of this episode now. Let's do it.
说到关于童年的表格，他会写什么呢？他从四岁到六岁都被排挤，因为他没有把金枪鱼罐头里多余的油留下来。我的意思是，他说这就像用沉默给人一记耳光。哎呀。是的。好吧，让我们进入这一集的主线剧情吧。开始吧。
Michael has a talking head where he explains that today is safety training day. And it's going to be led by Toby. He really hopes Toby isn't going to mess it up. Right. But first, they're all going to go down to the warehouse and listen to Daryl's presentation about safety in the warehouse. It's going to be Zoppity. It's going to be Zoppity.
迈克尔有一个访谈片段，他解释说今天是安全培训日。将由托比来主持。他真心希望托比不要搞砸了。对。但首先，他们都要去仓库听达里尔关于仓库安全的演讲。这会很棒的。这会很棒的。
You know, Dwight is like, all right, let's get down to the warehouse, right? everyone's like filing down the hallway. There is a deleted scene that I loved. It's just a quick snippet. But these are the things I loved about our show. Dwight is saying, everybody, buddy up. Like, why is he saying that? And I'm walking down the hallway and Meredith is like a step or two behind me.
你知道，德怀特说，好了，我们去仓库吧，对吧？大家都在走廊里排队走下去。有一个我非常喜欢的删除片段。只是一个简短的片段。但这些就是我喜欢我们这部剧的原因。德怀特说，大家，找个搭档。他为什么要这么说？我正走在走廊上，梅雷迪思就在我身后一两步远。
And Dwight's like, everyone, buddy up. And Angela Martin grabs Meredith's hand. And Meredith is like, don't hold my freaking hand. And it's like three seconds. And I just loved it. I love that. It's so funny. It's like you're not evacuating from the building.
德怀特又说，大家，找个搭档。安吉拉·马丁抓住了梅雷迪思的手。梅雷迪思说，别抓我该死的手。这只有三秒钟。但我太喜欢了。我喜欢那个。太搞笑了。就像你们不是在撤离大楼一样。
You're just going to the warehouse. I know, but whatever Dwight is doing, I'm like, I'm on board. Okay, buddy up. Well, when we get down to the warehouse, these are some of my favorite scenes of all time. Led by Craig Robinson. Oh, man, I love it when Craig has the floor. I love it when he's in charge and Michael has to listen to him. He is just trying to deliver information that is important.
你们只是要去仓库。我知道，但无论德怀特在做什么，我都觉得，我加入。好吧，找个搭档。嗯，当我们到达仓库时，这些是我有史以来最喜欢的场景之一。由克雷格·罗宾逊主持。哦，天哪，我喜欢克雷格掌控全场的时候。我喜欢他负责，而迈克尔必须听他指挥的时候。他只是想传达重要的信息。
Yes. And he has to deal with Michael. You know, it reminds me very much of watching my first graders Zoom classes. Oh, trying to keep people on task. Yes. The teacher is like, what is three plus two? And everyone's like, I got a new puppy. It's loud outside.
是的。而且他必须应付迈克尔。你知道，这让我想起了看我一年级学生的Zoom网课。哦，试图让大家保持专注。是的。老师问，三加二等于几？每个人都说，我有一只新小狗。外面很吵。
My mom likes wine. And the teacher is like, what is three plus two? that is this is what it reminds me of it Daryl trying to talk to all of us about this forklift and this baler yeah you know Harold Ramos talked about Craig and about how brilliant of an actor he thought he was and how he felt like Craig was a naturalistic actor like it was so natural this dialogue coming out of him that you you just wholeheartedly believe him it never seems scripted right Like everything about his cadence, like all of it, it is. It's amazing. Yeah. I was sort of studying that. That's so funny that Harald Ramis said that because I was studying that. I was like, how does he make it seem so natural? I mean, Craig is really brilliant, guys. He's super talented. Craig, come be on the podcast. I reached out to him. We've traded some messages. It's going to happen. We just have to figure out dates.
我妈妈喜欢红酒。老师又问，三加二等于几？这让我想起了达里尔试图和我们所有人谈论叉车和打包机。是的，你知道哈罗德·雷米斯谈到克雷格，谈到他认为他是一位多么出色的演员，以及他觉得克雷格是一位自然主义的演员，他口中说出的台词是如此自然，以至于你完全相信他，这看起来一点也不像剧本写出来的，对吧？就像他的节奏感一样，这一切，太神奇了。是的。我当时正在研究这个。哈罗德·雷米斯这么说太搞笑了，因为我当时也在研究。我在想，他是怎么让它看起来如此自然的？我的意思是，克雷格真的很棒，伙计们。他非常有天赋。克雷格，来参加我们的播客吧。我联系过他。我们交换过一些信息。这会发生的。我们只需要确定日期。
Let's lock it up, Craig. Let's lock it up. Well, as Darrell is. explaining the dangers of the bailer, for example. Michael is making a ton of jokes. And he's trying to suck up to Dwight. And this is when people start making bets, right? Yes, this is the other storyline of the whole episode. So Darrell is about to say, do you know how many people lose an arm in a bailer each year? Kevin and Jim decide to bet on what they think the answer is. Yes, exactly. It happens around four minutes. I want to share with you that Mindy said something that really made me laugh in the DVD commentary. She said that in the writer's room, they were talking about this bailer, and they really saw it as a scary, big piece of machinery, like maybe it had blades or something. And when they got it,
让我们定下来吧，克雷格。让我们定下来吧。嗯，当达里尔在解释打包机的危险时，例如。迈克尔开了好多玩笑。他试图讨好德怀特。这就是大家开始打赌的时候，对吧？是的，这是整集故事的另一条线索。所以达里尔正要说，你知道每年有多少人因为打包机失去手臂吗？凯文和吉姆决定打赌他们认为答案是多少。是的，没错。这发生在四分钟左右。我想和你们分享明迪在DVD评论中说的一件事，这真的让我笑了。她说在编剧室里，他们谈论这个打包机时，他们真的把它看作是一个可怕的大型机械，可能带有刀片之类的东西。当他们拿到它时，
she said it just looked like a big telephone booth. Yes. That moved really slowly. Well, I talked to Kent Sabornaq about this bailer, and he said that it was a real working bailer. Yeah. We had an actual safety meeting. Remember, Jenna? Yes. When we went into the warehouse to shoot, our second AD held a safety meeting that was like, guys, we have a forklift. We have a bailer.
她说它看起来就像一个巨大的电话亭。是的。移动得非常缓慢。嗯，我和肯特·萨博纳克谈过这个打包机，他说这是一个真正能工作的打包机。是的。我们进行了一次真正的安全会议。记得吗，珍娜？是的。当我们进入仓库拍摄时，我们的第二副导演举行了一次安全会议，内容是，伙计们，我们有一台叉车。我们有一台打包机。
Do not touch anything. Yeah. These are real machines. He said that he called the manufacturer Olympic wire and equipment, and they donate. a bailer because they got like free product placement so that we got a free bailer. Well, I want to say that there is this little part at the end of the bailer conversation where it's going on and on, right? Yeah.
什么都不要碰。是的。这些是真正的机器。他说他给制造商奥林匹克电线和设备公司打了电话，他们捐赠了一台打包机，因为他们获得了免费的产品植入，所以我们得到了一台免费的打包机。嗯，我想说的是，在打包机对话的最后有一小部分，它一直在持续，对吧？是的。
And Darrell is like, so do you understand? And Michael is like, yes, only on the rarest occasion. Daryl is like, on no occasions. On no occasions. I had to look that up in the script. And I will tell you, that was not in the script. I think that was improvised. I feel like I remember that, too, being there.
达里尔说，那么，你们明白了吗？迈克尔说，是的，在极少数情况下。达里尔说，在任何情况下都不行。在任何情况下都不行。我不得不在剧本里查了一下。我告诉你们，那不在剧本里。我想那是即兴发挥的。我觉得我也记得那个，当时就在现场。
And we just let Steve and Craig go back and forth. Just go back and forth. And I, you know, it brought me back, Angela. I just loved shooting this episode. And part of it was because if you notice, we're all in these big group scenes almost all the time. Yeah. This was an episode of big group scenes. And not just that.
我们只是让史蒂夫和克雷格来回互动。就来回互动。而且，你知道，这让我想起了过去，安吉拉。我太喜欢拍摄这一集了。部分原因是如果你注意到了，我们几乎一直都在这些大型群戏中。是的。这一集全是大型群戏。不仅如此。
We also got to work with Patrice and Craig and Carly. We had all the warehouse folks, too. We were all together all the time. And it really is rare. I mean, it happened in the basketball episode. It happened in this one, some Christmas parties and things like that. But it was rare, and we would all just have a great time. And I liked it, too, because it was such a simple idea.
我们还和帕特里斯、克雷格和卡莉一起工作。我们还有所有的仓库员工。我们一直都在一起。这真的很罕见。我的意思是，这在篮球那一集发生过。在这一集也发生了，还有一些圣诞派对之类的。但这很罕见，我们大家都会玩得很开心。我也喜欢它，因为它是一个如此简单的想法。
It's just safety training day. I know. That's it. And it goes off the rails. and we're all in, like, all of us are now on this roller coaster. Yeah. Well, I have to say before we leave the scene, I absolutely love that Michael cannot remember Madge's name. He can't.
这只是安全培训日。我知道。就是这样。然后它就失控了。我们都在，就像我们所有人现在都在这趟过山车上。是的。嗯，在离开这个场景之前，我必须说，我绝对喜欢迈克尔记不住马奇的名字。他记不住。
No. He calls her patch, pudge. He cannot remember her name. My mom cannot remember a name that is just slightly different, just slightly different. Here's an example. When I was in college, my roommate's boyfriend's name was Bart. B-A-R-T, B-A-R-T, Bart. And the day I met him, my mom was with me.
不。他叫她帕奇、帕奇。他记不住她的名字。我妈妈记不住稍微有点不同的名字，只是稍微有点不同。这里有个例子。我在上大学时，我室友男朋友的名字叫巴特。B-A-R-T，巴特。我见到他的那天，我妈妈和我在一起。
And the minute he was like, hi, I'm Bart, I thought, nope, not going to happen. Nope, it's never going to get that one. What did she call him? For years. For years, she called him Mart. How's Mark? I'm like, Mom, it's Bart. What did I say?
就在他打招呼说，嗨，我是巴特的那一刻，我想，不，这不可能。不，她永远记不住这个名字。她叫他什么？好几年。好几年，她都叫他马特。马特怎么样了？我说，妈，是巴特。我说了什么？
You said Mart. I did? Yes, you did. Wow. Who would name their child Mart? I don't know. I don't know. No, but like, who would name their kid Patch or Padge or Pudge?
你说的是马特。我说了吗？是的，你说了。哇。谁会给孩子起名叫马特？我不知道。我不知道。不，但是，谁会给孩子起名叫帕奇或帕奇或帕奇？
It's like, you're so right. By the way, I apologize in advance for our listener named Mart. I would also like to apologize to anyone named Patch or Pudge. Well, now we're going to go upstairs, Angela. Toby is going to teach his safety meeting. For whatever reason, Michael has forced everyone from the warehouse to come to this presentation. Paul Lieberstein knocks this out of the park. As great as Daryl was in the warehouse, Paul is as Toby in the office.
就像，你说得太对了。顺便说一句，我提前为我们那位名叫马特的听众道歉。我也想向任何名叫帕奇或帕奇的人道歉。好吧，现在我们要上楼了，安吉拉。托比要教他的安全会议。不管出于什么原因，迈克尔强迫仓库里的每个人都来参加这个演讲。保罗·利伯斯坦把这一段演得太棒了。就像达里尔在仓库里表现得一样出色，保罗作为托比在办公室里也一样出色。
Yes. His list of things, guys, to be prepared for. Are you ready for them? Toby's office safety training. Carpal tunnel syndrome. Poor circulation. Computer, screen, eye strain. And you might want to keep a sweater or cardigan in case it gets drafty.
是的。伙计们，他准备的清单。你们准备好了吗？托比的办公室安全培训。腕管综合症。血液循环不良。电脑屏幕眼睛疲劳。而且你可能想准备一件毛衣或开衫，以防有穿堂风。
Yeah. Michael is so frustrated. He can't take it. None of these things. are as exciting as getting your arm cut off in a bailor. He can't take it. At five minutes, 52 seconds, Ryan says, what about a long sleeve tea? Yeah.
是的。迈克尔太沮丧了。他受不了了。这些事情都没有在打包机里被切断手臂那么令人兴奋。他受不了了。在五分五十二秒时，瑞安说，长袖T恤怎么样？是的。
Here's a great story about that. According to BJ, there was a huge joke debate about that line. What about a long sleeve tea? And at 2 a.m. in the writer's room, they were debating it. Mike Scher said, no, this is a ridiculous line. And Greg was all for it. This is so funny that they spent time debating this line. I know.
这里有一个关于那个的很棒的故事。据BJ说，关于那句台词有一场巨大的笑话辩论。长袖T恤怎么样？在凌晨两点的编剧室里，他们还在争论。迈克·谢尔说，不，这是一句荒谬的台词。而格雷格完全支持它。他们花时间争论这句台词太搞笑了。我知道。
I know. I love this line. Me too. And it gets called back later when we're asked to go downstairs. I know. I love it. Well, maybe that's why B.J. delivered it so Riley is because it got in.
我知道。我喜欢这句台词。我也是。而且后来当我们被要求下楼时，它又被呼应了。我知道。我喜欢它。嗯，也许这就是为什么BJ说得那么好，因为它被保留下来了。
He knew the backstory of this debate in the writer's room over that line. We had a fan question about another line in this little bit. Okay. Sarah Bell, Dagne, Albano, and Katie Boyd all asked, when Michael's reading the safety booklet and he says office life causes a sedimentary lifestyle. Was that improv or was that in the script? That was not in the script. You're kidding.
他知道编剧室里关于那句台词的辩论背景。我们有一个粉丝问题是关于这一小段里的另一句台词。好的。莎拉·贝尔、达格尼·阿尔巴诺和凯蒂·博伊德都问，当迈克尔读安全手册并说办公室生活导致久坐不动的生活方式时。那是即兴发挥还是剧本里的？那不在剧本里。你在开玩笑吧。
There's a little bit of banter there between Michael and Toby that looked like it veered a little bit off script like they were having a little fun with it. Oh, I love that. So Michael has had it. He takes over. He's like, Toby, I'm going to do the safety training. and he wants to show the warehouse people that working in an office is just as dangerous. And he says, oh, there's seasonal affective disorder. Like dim light can lead to depression.
迈克尔和托比之间有一些玩笑，看起来有点偏离了剧本，就像他们玩得很开心一样。哦，我喜欢那个。所以迈克尔受够了。他接管了。他说，托比，我要来做安全培训。他想向仓库的人展示在办公室工作同样危险。他说，哦，有季节性情感障碍。就像昏暗的灯光会导致抑郁。
And the warehouse people, they're out. They're like, yeah, dim light's a bitch. You live a little sweet nerfy life sitting on your biscuit, never having to risk it. And Michael is, he's just so bummed out. He really wanted to prove to these guys that. Things get just as crazy up in the office. It's such a weird thing to take a stand on. I know.
而仓库的人，他们不买账。他们说，是的，昏暗的灯光真是糟糕。你坐在饼干上过着甜蜜的软生活，从来不需要冒险。迈克尔，他真的很沮丧。他真的很想向这些人证明，办公室里的事情也同样疯狂。这真是一个奇怪的立场。我知道。
It's such a Michael Scott thing to become so invested in this. He just wants to be cool, Jenna. He's fascinated by the warehouse guys. Oh, yeah. He really is. And this tracks from previous episodes. And he especially wants them to think he's cool. Yeah, he wants to win their favor.
这真是迈克尔·斯科特式的行为，变得如此投入。他只是想变酷，珍娜。他被仓库的人迷住了。哦，是的。他确实是。这可以追溯到之前的剧集。他特别希望他们认为他很酷。是的，他想赢得他们的好感。
Yeah. Well, now Kevin, Jim, Oscar, and Karen are all guys. gathered around Pam's desk. And for whatever reason, they are trying to guess how many jelly beans are in her little dispenser. Yeah. It's now taken over. This whole sort of bedding from the warehouse. It's how they're going to pass their day. Jim wins. Jim thought 50. Karen went with 51. Turns out there were 49. Yeah. And then at eight minutes, 39 seconds, Kevin says, it's not fair because Jim has spent countless hours talking to Pam at front reception. I mean, hours and hours.
是的。嗯，现在凯文、吉姆、奥斯卡和凯伦都聚集在帕姆的办公桌旁。不管出于什么原因，他们都在试图猜她的小分配器里有多少颗软糖。是的。这现在已经接管了一切。这种来自仓库的打赌方式。这就是他们打发时间的方式。吉姆赢了。吉姆认为是50。凯伦猜的是51。结果是49。是的。然后在八分三十九秒时，凯文说，这不公平，因为吉姆在接待处和帕姆聊了无数个小时。我的意思是，几个小时又几个小时。
Yeah. Oh, awkward. I would like you guys to know that I kept Pam's candy dispenser when we wrapped. What? You're just now telling us this? One year we've been doing this podcast. One year we've talked about, what did you take from set? Yeah.
是的。哦，尴尬。我想让你们知道，我们在拍摄结束时我留下了帕姆的糖果分配器。什么？你现在才告诉我们？我们做这个播客已经一年了。我们谈论了一年，你从片场带走了什么？是的。
Where is it? Yeah, I have it. It's in my office. It's a little plastic. It's so simple. I know. And it has a little like silver scooper. And it has a little little little.
它在哪里？是的，我有它。它在我的办公室里。它是一个小塑料制品。太简单了。我知道。它有一个小小的银色勺子。它有一个小小的。
lid you lift up. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Do you keep... Yeah, and people never use the silver scooper. What they would do is they would just open it and shake it into their hand, which, by the way, was just as sanitary and effective. But I always use the silver scooper because I'm a big fan of tiny cutlery. You're also a big fan of desserts that come in a very small size. With a very tiny spoon. Yeah, you love that. I like eating with tiny cutlery. Do you follow Tiny Kitchen? Yes, from TastMade. Yes. Where they make a teeny tiny meal in a teeny tiny kitchen.
你掀开的盖子。嗯哼。是的。你留着……是的，人们从来不用那个银色勺子。他们会做的是直接打开它，把它摇到手里，顺便说一句，这同样卫生且有效。但我总是用那个银色勺子，因为我是微型餐具的忠实粉丝。你也是非常小尺寸甜点的忠实粉丝。用一个小勺子。是的，你喜欢那个。我喜欢用微型餐具吃饭。你关注“微型厨房”吗？是的，来自TastMade。是的。他们在微型厨房里制作微型餐点。
Yes. It's mesmerizing. It's mesmerizing. I did a really fun project with TastMade with my husband Josh, and we got to go tour the tiny kitchen. Jenna, are you there? I can't speak. Are you okay? I can't speak.
是的。太迷人了。太迷人了。我和我丈夫乔什一起做了一个非常有趣的项目，我们参观了微型厨房。珍娜，你在吗？我说不出话来。你还好吗？我说不出话来。我不敢相信你竟然亲眼看到了微型厨房。哦，天哪。太酷了。太酷了。它真的很小吗？它真的很小。还有做那个的女士。当她在小煎锅里做小鸡蛋时，用一个小铲子。是的。而且你知道烤箱，他们放了一个小小的蜡烛。一个小茶。它们叫什么？茶蜡。它们叫什么？是的，像茶蜡烛。茶蜡烛。他们确实在炉子上煮东西，他们用一个小蜡烛。你需要去看看。你会喜欢的。伙计们，太可爱了。去看看他们做小汉堡的那个视频。好吧。我们刚才说到哪了？
I thought you froze. I didn't freeze. I can't believe that you got to see the tiny kitchen in person. Oh my God. It's so cool. It's so cool. Is it so tiny? It's so tiny. And the lady that does it. A little bitty spatula when she like makes the little egg on the little bay pan. Yes. And and you know the oven they put a little tiny like candle. A little tea. What are they called? Tea lights. What are they called? Yeah, like a tea candle. Tea candle. They do, they really do cook things on the stove pot and they use a little candle. You need to go see it. You'll love it. Guys, it's so cute. Look up the one where they make a little hamburger. All right. Where were we?
我不知道。我们谈论微型餐具和微型厨房完全迷失了方向。我知道我们在哪。迈克尔把帕姆叫进办公室，询问她关于抑郁症的严重性与在打包机旁工作的威胁的看法。是的。是的。我对这次谈话感到非常兴奋，珍娜，因为我觉得这是一个非常精彩、非常微妙的对《罪犯》一集的呼应。因为帕姆说，你知道吗，仓库的人有视觉辅助。哦，天哪，迈克尔灵光一现。如果你能看他的脸，他在九分十七秒时，看史蒂夫作为迈克尔的脸，当他说，是的，你说得太对了。
I don't know. We got completely lost talking about tiny cutlery and tiny kitchens. I know where we are. Michael has called Pam into her office to ask her opinion on the seriousness of depression versus the threat of working with a bailer. Yeah. Yeah. I got very excited about this conversation, Jenna, because I thought it was a fantastic, very subtle callback to the convict. Because Pam says, you know what, the warehouse guys had visuals on their side. Oh, my gosh, light bulb for Michael. If you could look at his face, he's, okay, at nine minutes, 17 seconds, look at Steve's face as Michael when he's like, yeah, you're so right.
这就是缺少的全部。这就是缺少的全部。是的。记得吗，我们在《罪犯》的删除片段中了解到，猫头鹰胡特来到他的学校，在那一刻他意识到如果你想让人们听你说话，你必须有服装。
That's all that was missing. That's all that was missing. Yeah. Remember, we learned in the convict from the deleted scene that hoot the owl, came to his school and in that moment he realized if you want people to hear you you have to have a costume
你必须有一些道具，你必须有视觉辅助。好吧，迈克尔现在行动起来了。现在他把德怀特叫进办公室，他说我们需要方法来展示办公室员工面临的迫在眉睫的抑郁威胁。
you have to have some props you have to have visual aids well Michael is often running now now he calls Dwight into his office and he's like we need ways to illustrate the imminent threat of depression faced by office workers
而且，好吧，我非常确定这一切要么是即兴发挥，要么是当天给他们的，因为剧本里这一幕只有四行长。但是在这里，当德怀特建议做一个被子时，迈克尔说一个抑郁被子，迈克尔说，没有时间缝一个。那是最好的回应。
and okay I am pretty sure all of this was either improv or like given to them on the day because this scene in the script is about four lines long. But here, when Dwight suggests a quilt, and Michael says a depression quilt, Michael is like, there's no time to sew one. That is the greatest response.
这不像，不，那是个坏主意。这就像，是的，如果我们有时间就好了。那会很完美。我觉得这是很多即兴发挥，因为删除片段里还有额外的内容。他们没完没了。哦，有那么好吗？很有趣。真的很有趣。
It's not like, no, that's a bad idea. It's like, yes, if only we had time. That would be perfect. I think this was a lot of improv because there's also extra in the deleted scenes. They go on and on. Oh, is it so good? It's fun. It's really fun.
而且迈克尔让德怀特非常激动。就像，德怀特立刻就加入了。我喜欢迈克尔说，你知道我们的杀手是什么吗。迈克尔说抑郁症，德怀特说狼。是的。那让我大声笑了出来。哦，天哪。他们两个在一起太棒了。
And Michael has Dwight so worked up. Like, Dwight is so immediately on board. I love the line when Michael says, you know what our killer is. And Michael says depression and Dwight says wolves. Yes. That made me laugh out loud. Oh, my gosh. Those two together are so brilliant.
好吧，现在我们去停车场，迈克尔正在蹦床上跳。他让德怀特联系了那个巨大的大男孩玩具店。我查过了。你知道，根本没有那家店。哦，好吧。那是编出来的。嗯，我喜欢的是。
Well, now we go to the parking lot where Michael. is bouncing on a trampoline. He had Dwight reach out to the giant big boy toy store. I looked up. There isn't one just so you know. Oh, okay. That was made up. Well, what I love is the
背景中盒子和所有包装的细节。哦，那是一个很棒的细节。是的，所以这是装在一个盒子里来的，他们必须组装它。他要上屋顶，他要让德怀特把大家都叫到外面。然后。
detail in the background of the box and all the packaging that's in the background. Oh, that's a great detail. Yeah, so this came in a box and they had to assemble it. He's going to go up on the roof and he's going to have Dwight call everyone outside. And then
他要假装从屋顶跳下去，以此作为展示如果你的抑郁症不加控制会发生什么的一种方式。这是一种视觉上教导大家的方法。没错。在他从屋顶跳下去后，他会多跳几下，只是为了好玩，然后他会绕过拐角，揭示他还活着，他很好。这是迈克尔的大计划。这会向大家展示。
he is going to pretend to jump off the roof as a way of illustrating what can happen if your depression goes unchecked. And it was a way to visually teach everyone. That's right. And after he jumps off the roof, he's going to take a few extra bounces just for fun before he walks around the corner to reveal that he is alive, that he's fine. This is Michael's big plan. This is going to show everyone.
可能会出什么问题？我这里有一个来自哈罗德·雷米斯的小花絮。我要和你们分享。他们在评论中谈到，最初的想法是每个人都上屋顶去劝迈克尔放弃这个念头。每个人。哦。是的。哈罗德说，我不认为这真的能体现出他正在考虑的事情有多严重。
What could go wrong? I have a little nugget here from Harold Ramos. I'm going to share it with you. So they talked about in the commentary that originally the idea was that everyone went up on the roof to talk Michael out of this. Everyone. Oh. Yeah. And Harold was like, I don't think it really sells how serious, like what he's contemplating.
我想如果他在屋顶上，对着停车场里的每个人大喊大叫，你有那个从屋顶扫向他，再向下，再向上的摄像机镜头，你真的能感觉到这是一个多么可怕的主意。是的，那是哈罗德。哈罗德说，不，伙计们，其他人应该在停车场。只有迈克尔在屋顶上。我只是觉得那真的很棒。嗯，我知道他们可能想让我们上屋顶，因为从技术上讲，拍摄声音和摄像会更容易。这在技术上是如此困难。
I think if he's on the roof and he's shouting down to everyone in the party. parking lot and you have that whip camera panning from the roof back to him and down and up, you really get the sense of what a horrible idea this is. Yeah, that was Harold. Harold was like, no, guys, everyone else should be in the parking lot. Only Michael on the roof. I just thought that was really great. Well, I know that they probably wanted us up on the roof because technically it would be easier to shoot with sound and camera. It was it was such a technically difficult. episode and I remember that. I remember how difficult it was for them to get angles on all of us and him and the bright sun and the sound. Kudos to our crew because it doesn't seem like it was
一集，我记得。我记得他们要捕捉我们所有人、他、明亮的阳光和声音的角度有多么困难。向我们的剧组致敬，因为看起来并不像。
difficult, but it was actually really technically difficult. Yeah. And to Steve and the guys that were on the roof, just the limited crew up there with him, they were up on that roof for a really long time. Yeah. Yeah, they were. Well, now back in the office, the whole betting game is still going. People are placing bets on how long it's going to take Kelly to explain to Ryan how Netflix works. They're betting like how many times she's going to say the word awesome and what movies she mentions and how long it takes. It's heated. Yes. We find out that Kelly talked for two minutes and 42 seconds.
困难，但实际上在技术上非常困难。是的，还有史蒂夫和在屋顶上的伙计们，只有有限的剧组人员和他在一起，他们在那个屋顶上待了很长时间。是的。是的，他们待了很久。嗯，现在回到办公室，整个打赌游戏还在继续。人们在打赌凯利向瑞安解释Netflix是如何运作需要多长时间。他们打赌她会说多少次“太棒了”这个词，她提到了哪些电影，以及需要多长时间。很激烈。是的。我们发现凯利说了两分四十二秒。
She said the word awesome 12 times and mentioned six romantic comedies. And never had a clue as people were like putting money on the table next to Ryan. Well, we had a fan question from a lot. Elizabeth Myers, who says, old tech alert, can you guys explain this Netflix scene? What is a queue? What is a cue? You guys, yes. I didn't even think of that. Netflix. You remember old Netflix, right, Angela? Yeah, yeah, yeah. You'd put it in your queue. Like, it was like a list of what you were going to watch. Because you got a DVD in the mail. Yeah. It didn't just come up on your TV. So you would have to go to the Netflix website and, pick what DVDs you want them to send to you, and you could pick the order.
她说了12次“太棒了”，提到了六部浪漫喜剧。而且瑞安旁边的人在桌子上放钱时，她根本没察觉。嗯，我们有一个来自很多人的粉丝问题。伊丽莎白·迈尔斯说，旧技术警报，你们能解释一下这个Netflix场景吗？什么是队列？什么是队列？伙计们，是的。我甚至没想过那个。Netflix。你还记得旧的Netflix，对吧，安吉拉？是的，是的，是的。你会把它放进你的队列里。就像，它就像一个你要观看的列表。因为你通过邮件收到一张DVD。是的。它不是直接出现在你的电视上。所以你必须去Netflix网站，选择你想要他们寄给你的DVD，你可以选择顺序。
And then when you were done watching it, you put it in this like prepaid postage envelope and you sent it back. And whenever they got the one that you sent back, they would send you the next one in your queue. Yeah. It was like a mail-in blockbuster, basically. It was revolutionary because the idea was you didn't have to drive to the video store anymore to rent your videos.
然后当你看完它时，你把它放进这个预付邮资的信封里，然后把它寄回去。每当他们收到你寄回的那一张时，他们就会寄给你队列里的下一张。是的。它基本上就像一个邮寄版的百视达。它是革命性的，因为想法是你不再需要开车去视频店租你的视频了。
The problem was, though, sometimes you'd be like waiting for, you. your next thing to come up in your queue. Yeah. So, lady, this whole Netflix queue thing, it reminded me of how my parents got the DVD mail Netflix service for like ever, for like ever. They would not switch to the streaming one. Why? Why wouldn't they switch?
不过问题是，有时你会等待你的下一件东西出现在你的队列里。是的。所以，女士，整个Netflix队列的事情，让我想起了我父母是如何永远使用DVD邮件Netflix服务的。他们就是不肯换成流媒体的。为什么？为什么他们不换？
I don't know, but they did the DVD thing forever. And I texted them about it. I had to know. And their responses were so funny. My mom said I could share them. Okay. So you said, what did you, wait, what did you text them? I texted, hey guys, how long ago did you switch from the old Netflix service of getting
我不知道，但他们永远都在用DVD那个东西。我给他们发了短信问这件事。我必须知道。他们的回复太搞笑了。我妈妈说我可以分享它们。好的。所以你说，你，等等，你给他们发了什么短信？我发了，嘿，伙计们，你们多久以前从通过邮件获取物理DVD的旧Netflix服务切换到获取流媒体服务的？好的。他们分别给我回了短信。好的。好的。我爸爸给我回了短信。不记得了，挺久了。好的。
physical DVDs in the mail to getting the streaming service? Okay. They texted me back separately. Okay. Okay. My dad texted me back. Don't remember quite a while. Okay.
结束。我妈妈回了短信。爸爸在割草，但我认为我可以帮你。也许这就是为什么他的短信那么简短。是的，我想是这样。这说得通。好的。然后她说，很久以前，我和一个朋友吃午饭，她告诉我我们可以以每月9.95美元的价格获得Netflix有线频道。我们当时付那么多钱只是为了每月在邮件里收到两部电影。所以那时我们注册并取消了我们的其他计划。这很有趣，因为我一直想在有线电视上获得Netflix，但爸爸一直告诉我它太贵了。我的意思是，你知道爸爸对钱的态度。
The end. My mom texted. back. Dad's mowing the lawn, but I think I can help you. Maybe that's why his text was so brief. Yeah, I think so. It made sense. Okay. And then she said, a while back, I was having lunch with a friend, and she told me that we could get Netflix the cable channel for $9.95 a month. We were paying that just to get two movies a month in the mail. So that's when we signed up and dropped our other plan. It's funny because I had wanted to get Netflix on cable, but Dad kept telling me it was too expensive. I mean, you know how Dad is about money.
所以，我们使用Netflix流媒体大概有三年了。但爸爸不喜欢你必须为某些电影额外付费。我真的很想看电影《法蒂玛》，但你必须为此付费，而他不会这么做。但我会再次赢得这场战斗。你知道它是怎么运作的。哦，天哪。那真是太有层次了，充满了信息。首先，我喜欢她说爸爸在割草，然后我喜欢她说很久以前我吃午饭，因为你会想，等等，什么，我们要去哪，发生了什么？我知道，我知道，但是是的，所以我想大概三年前，我父母还在通过邮件接收DVD，我记得是因为我会问他们，你知道，我会问他们，他们当时迷上了《唐顿庄园》。
So, we've had Netflix streaming for, I'd say, three years now. But Dad does not like it when you have to pay extra for certain movies. I really want to watch the movie Fatima, but you have to pay for it and he won't do it. But I will once again win this battle. You know how it works. Oh, my gosh. that is so layered that is so jam-packed with information first of all I love that she's like dad is mowing then I love that she's like a few a while back I was having lunch because you're like wait what where are we going what's happening I know I know but yes so I guess three years only three years ago my parents were still getting DVDs in the mail and I remember because I would ask them you know I would be like how they were in love with Downton Abbey
《唐顿庄园》。我会问，你们看到哪一季了？他们说，嗯，我们在等下一季。它还没来。是的，它就在那里。订阅就行了。它就在那里。哦，天哪。他们在等他们的DVD。那真是，那真是太神奇了。好吧。我们休息一下，然后回来谈谈屋顶上的那些西瓜？是的。而且我从肯特百科全书那里得到了一些关于西瓜的好信息。嗯，我想听听。好吧，好的。我们马上回来。当你的投资者、客户和员工对你的业务提出更多要求时，用SAP实现它。SAP的人工智能功能可以帮助你精简成本、与新供应商建立联系并管理工资单，即使你的业务正被拉向不同的方向。以公平的价格提供优质产品，同时支付给员工他们应得的报酬，这样你的业务就能保持从容。
Mountain Abbey. And I'd be like, what season are you on? And they're like, well, we're waiting for the next season. It hasn't come yet. Yes, it's right there. Just subscribe. It's right there. Oh, my gosh. They're waiting for their DVD. That is, that is amazing. All right. Should we take a break and then come back and talk about those watermelons on the roof? Yes. And I have some good info from Kentapedia about the watermelons. Well, I want to hear it. All right, good. We'll be right back. When your investors, customers, and workers demand more from your business, make it happen with SAP. The AI-powered capabilities of SAP can help you streamline costs, connect with new suppliers, and manage payroll, even when your business is being pulled in different directions. To deliver a quality product at a fair price, while paying your people what they're worth too, so your business can stay unfazed.
在SAP.com/uncertainty了解更多。西蒙斯在那个时代庆祝表达的自由。模式的力量在于其无限的可能性。每一件衣服都是对创造力的邀请，一种独特性，一种肯定你就是你自己的自由。
Learn more at SAP.com slash uncertainty. Simons is celebrated the liberty of expression at a time. The power of the mode resides in its possibilities infinite. Each vatement is an invitation to creativity, a singularity, to the liberty to affirm that you are
就像你让。去成为，去感受，去感受生活，并以一种时尚的方式面对世界，杂志在
as you are like you let. For to be to feel, and to feel live and affront the world as a fashion with Aplom, magazineed at
西蒙斯。哦，嗨，伙计。谁是最好的你？我真希望我能整天和你在一起。呃，戴夫，你没静音。嘿，这种事发生在最好的人身上。享受一些金鱼切达饼干。金鱼的记忆力很短。
Symons. Oh, hi, buddy. Who's the best you are? I wish I could spend all day with you instead. Uh, Dave, you're off mute. Hey, happens to the best of us. Enjoy some goldfish cheddar crackers. Goldfish have short memories.
像金鱼一样。哦，就是这个。你终于要求升职的那一天。你站在镜子前，拿着你的星巴克咖啡。要自信。果断。记住眼神交流。但也要记得眨眼。
Be like goldfish. Oh, this is it. The day you finally ask for that big promotion. You're in front of your mirror with your Starbucks coffee. Be confident. Assertive. Remember eye contact. But also remember to blink.
微笑，但不要太多。那很奇怪。如果你工作做得不好怎么办？如果他们反而让你降职怎么办？好吧。别傻了。你很聪明。你很有动力。
Smile, but not too much. That's weird. What if you aren't any good at your job? What if they demo you instead? Okay. Don't be silly. You're smart. You're driven.
如果你一直对着镜子说话，你会迟到的。这次升职是你的。去争取吧。星巴克。从来不仅仅是咖啡。好吧。所以我们回来了。德怀特和迈克尔在屋顶上，他们正在进行某种实验，看看迈克尔必须跳多远才能落在蹦床上。
You're going to be late if you keep talking to the mirror. This promotion is yours. Go get them. Starbucks. It's never just coffee. All right. So we're back. Dwight and Michael are on the roof, and they are testing sort of an experiment to see how far Michael has to jump out to land on the trampoline.
他们带了一些西瓜，他们正在尝试。所以，女士，我联系了肯特百科全书，因为我有两个问题。好的。第一，我想知道，史蒂夫和雷恩是怎么上屋顶的，谁和他们在一起？他们必须坐你和约翰坐的那种东西吗？是的。他们必须使用那个大型剪叉式升降机，每个人都必须穿安全带。
And they've got some watermelons, and they're giving it a go. So, lady, I reached out to Kentapedia because I had two questions. Okay. Number one, I wanted to know, how did Steve and Rain get up on the roof and who all was up there with them? Did they have to ride that thing that you and John rode? Yes. They had to use that big scissor lift and everyone had to wear a safety harness
但这是肯特这一季增加的新东西。什么？肯特雇了一些特技演员在舞台屋顶上安装安全绳，这样如果剧组人员必须上去进行照明工作，他们就能穿上安全带。
but here was something new that Kent added this season. What? Kent hired some stunt guys to rig safety cable up on the roof of the stage so that if there was ever a time where the crew had to be up there to do lighting, they would be able to wear a safety harness
并将自己扣在安全绳上。所以对于这一幕，史蒂夫、雷恩和兰德尔（我们的摄影师）在服装下都穿了安全带，他们也都扣在了安全绳上。所以这也可能涉及服装部门。
and clip themselves onto a safety cable. So for this scene, Steve and Rain and Randall, who was our cinematographer, they all had safety harnesses underneath their costumes and they were clipped onto the safety cable as well. So that also probably involved the wardrobe department
因为她必须确保他们的西装足够大，能穿在安全带外面。是的。我还有一个关于西瓜的问题。哦，好的。而且我并不孤单。劳伦·布莱特韦尔、梅根·基尔、塞拉·贝格利、菲比·博诺和麦迪·麦基都想知道有多少。
because she would have had to have made sure their suits were big enough to go over the safety harness. Yes. I also had a question about the watermelons. Oh, okay. And I was not alone. Lauren Brightwell, Megan Keel, Sierra Begley, Phoebe Bono, and Maddie McKee all wanted to know how many
西瓜被用于蹦床测试场景。多少个？肯特告诉我，我们购买了12个西瓜，但在第10次拍摄左右，肯特对哈罗德·雷米斯说，我想我们需要用CGI来处理西瓜的事情，因为他从屋顶扔下的西瓜没有一个接近击中汽车。是的，他们在评论中谈到他们没有成功。直到第11次拍摄。哦，肯特说是最后一个西瓜，那是第12次拍摄。
watermelons were used for the trampoline test scene. How many? Kent told me that we purchased 12 watermelons, but around take 10, Kent said to Harold Ramos, I think we're going to need to CGI the watermelon thing because none of the watermelons that he was throwing off the roof were coming anywhere close to hitting the car. Yeah, they talk about it in the commentary that they weren't getting it. until take number 11. Oh, Kent said it was the last watermelon, that it was take 12.
哦，哈罗德说是……哈罗德·雷米斯说是第11次拍摄。哦，好吧，所以伙计们，要么是第11次要么是第12次，我想奇迹般地，它落在了蹦床上，完美地击中了汽车。我觉得史蒂夫和雷恩的表情是真实的，因为他们当时想，哦，天哪，我们终于做到了。嗯，你知道这让我想起了什么吗，安吉拉？这让我想起了那些“Dude Perfect”的家伙。
Oh, Harold was say it was... Harold Reamus said it was take number 11. Oh, well, so guys, it was either take 11 or 12, I guess by some miracle, it landed on the trampoline and it hit the car perfectly. And I feel like Steve and Rain's expression, like, is real because they were like, oh my God, we finally did it. Well, do you know what this reminded me of, Angela? This reminded me of those dude perfect guys.
你知道“Dude Perfect”吗？不，什么是“Dude Perfect”？好的。所以这是我儿子迷上了“Dude Perfect”。这就像篮球吗？就像你必须从一个疯狂的地方投篮？是的。他们是这些家伙。
Do you know Dude Perfect? No, what's Dude Perfect? Okay. So this is my son is obsessed with Dude Perfect. Is this like a basketball? Like you have to shoot a basketball from a crazy place? Yes. They are these guys.
他们来自德克萨斯州。他们通过在YouTube上做所有这些精心设计的特技投篮而出名。是的。但是，我的意思是，他们现在大多了。他们现在有现场巡演，你知道等等等等，但是的，他们会做这样的事情，他们会把西瓜从建筑物上扔到蹦床上，并试图用它击中什么东西。
They're from Texas. And they became famous by doing all of these elaborate trick shots. Yes. On YouTube. But, I mean, they're so much bigger now. They've got like a live. tour now and you know yada yada but yes they would have done something like this they would have thrown a watermelon off of a building onto a trampoline and tried to hit something with it and
德怀特和迈克尔的反应100%让我想起了我一直和我儿子一起看的这些“Dude Perfect”视频。是的，我看过那些视频。我不知道那些家伙的名字或者他们叫什么，但是的，我们的孩子喜欢那些东西。这也让我想到，也许我们需要和“Dude Perfect”在某种“Frawl thing”上合作。就像从树上掉下来，击中垃圾桶。是的。“Frawl thing”特技投篮，有办公室女士和“Dude Perfect”。这是我们一直在等待的合作。
Dwight and michael's reaction just 100% reminded me of these dude perfect videos that i've been watching with my son yes i have seen those videos i didn't know the guy's name or whatever they go by but yeah our kids love that stuff it also made me think that maybe we need to collaborate with Dude Perfect on some sort of a fral thing thing. So it's like off the tree, hit the trash can. Yeah. Frawl thing trick shots with office ladies and dude perfect. It's a collaboration we've all been waiting for.
还有威浮球。你，你刚才怎么说的？威浮。你在中间说了。威浮球。威浮球。你对我产生影响了。我知道。
And Wufel Ball. Did you, how did you say it just now? Wufel. You said it in the middle. Wiffle ball. Wiffle ball. You're rubbing off on me. I know.
我喜欢它。在我们离开之前有两件事。整个把西瓜从屋顶扔下来的时刻，珍娜。好的。第一，所有这些当他们看向蹦床的镜头，你可以看到街对面扣押场和所有火车的绝佳视野。我也注意到了。是的。
I love it. Two things before we leave. The whole walk. Watermelon Off the Roof moment, Jenna. Okay. Number one, all of these shots up here when they look out over to the trampoline, you can see a great view of the impound lot across the street with all the trains. I noticed it too. Yeah.
你真的看到了我们所在的地方，伙计们。当我们钱德勒谷工作室拍摄时，那是我们的邻居。是的。还有关于这个西瓜时刻的最后一件事，因为我觉得它太甜了。BJ在评论中说，这是那些时刻之一，珍娜。这让我想起了当你谈论在屋顶上，在那个温暖、美丽的夜晚吃那个烤奶酪三明治的时候，对吧？对BJ来说也是这样。他说，我有过这样一个时刻，我想，等一下，我和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔、雷恩·威尔逊和哈罗德·雷米斯在屋顶上。我们在扔西瓜。而且我还在拿工资。是的。我觉得那太甜了。这就是让我想起“Dude Perfect”的事情，因为我在想，这些就像一群在屋顶上扔西瓜的家伙，玩得很开心，但哦，他们在工作。是的。就像那是他们那天的工作。
You get a real slice of where we were, guys. Those were our neighbors when we filmed at Chandler Valley Studios. Yeah. And one last thing from this watermelon moment, because I just thought it was so sweet. B.J. in the commentary said that this was one of those moments, Jenna. It reminded me of when you talk about being on the roof, eating that grilled cheese sandwich on that warm, beautiful night, right? It was like that for BJ. He said, I had this moment where I was like, wait a second, I'm on a roof with Steve Correll and Rain Wilson and Harold Ramos. We're throwing watermelons. And I'm getting paid. Yes. I thought that was so sweet. That's what made me think of the dude perfect thing, because I was like, these are like a bunch of dudes up on a roof throwing watermelons down, just having a great time, but oh, they're at work. Yeah. Like that was their job that day.
我的意思是，多有趣。太有趣了。嗯，在我们继续之前，我还有关于这个场景的更多消息。好的。他们击中的那辆车是租来的。那是一辆克莱斯勒300道具车。猜猜他们花多少钱做了这个恶作剧。哦，天哪。我不知道。多少钱？他们弄凹了车顶，还弄坏了车的电动天窗。
I mean, how fun. So fun. Well, I have some more news about this scene before we move on. Okay. The car that they hit was a rental. It was a Chrysler 300 picture car. Guess how much money it cost them to do this gag. Oh my gosh. I don't know. How much? They dented the roof and they broke the electric moon roof of the car.
我是说，多有趣啊。太有趣了。好吧，在继续之前，关于这个场景我还有些消息要说。好的。他们撞的那辆车是租来的。那是一辆克莱斯勒300道具车。猜猜他们为了拍这个特技花了多少钱。天哪。我不知道。多少钱？他们撞凹了车顶，还弄坏了车的电动天窗。
From that one watermelon? Yeah, it cost $6,500 to fix it. Dang. Yeah. All right. Should we move back inside? Yes, because I texted Creed Bratton about this next scene. The betting is continuing. Everyone is watching Creed. Eat his apple. Creed doesn't know. They're all standing behind him. He sets the apple down. Jim walks by, puts a potato where the apple was. Will Creed notice he's now eating a potato and not an apple? Well, we got mail about this, Angela. Bianca H. Kayla O. Cassidy Price, Deanna Horn, and Merrily S. all asked, did Creed really take a bite out of a potato? Yeah. I texted him. What did he say? This is what he said. He wrote, I definitely bit right into that potato, and it wasn't half bad. Oh. So there you go. There you go. Well, Angela, it makes sense to me because in French, the word for apple is pom. And the word for potato is pom de terre, which means apple of the earth, or apple of the ground.
就那一个西瓜？是啊，修好它花了6500美元。天哪。是啊。好了。我们要回里面去吗？是的，因为我给克里德·布拉顿发了短信，说了接下来这一幕。赌局还在继续。每个人都在盯着克里德。吃他的苹果。克里德不知道。他们都站在他身后。他放下苹果。吉姆走过去，在苹果原来的位置放了一个土豆。克里德会发现他现在吃的是土豆而不是苹果吗？嗯，安吉拉，我们收到了关于这一幕的邮件。比安卡·H、凯拉·O、卡西迪·普莱斯、迪安娜·霍恩和梅里利·S都问，克里德真的咬了一口土豆吗？是的。我给他发了短信。他怎么说？他是这么说的。他写道，我确实直接咬了那个土豆，味道还不错。哦。所以就是这样。就是这样。嗯，安吉拉，这对我来说说得通，因为在法语中，苹果的词是pom。而土豆的词是pom de terre，意思是大地之果，或者地上的苹果。
I'm sorry. What is your logic? It makes sense to you that Creed would eat a potato and not know it wasn't an apple because it's the French word is palm de terre. Yeah. Okay. Potato in Indonesian is Kentang. What's apple? Apple is appell. Oh. Well, the French have related the apple and the potato in their language. Okay. And so perhaps they, I don't know. they're on to something. Perhaps Creed would do well in France. Yeah. I guess that's right. But as long as he doesn't try to pick him up himself at a market and thump them. Before we leave the whole Creed betting scene, at 12 minutes 38 seconds, you can see Angela sitting at her desk, watching everyone and judging. Oh. She's not participating, guys. She's not going to gamble. She's not going to bet on things. No. I remember I had a whole conversation with. with Harold about it. Like, where would Angela be in the bullpen? Would she be watching? You know, and she's reluctantly glancing over to see what the hubbub is about, but she will not participate. Well, Angela is a little bit of a busy body in the sense that she likes to know the goings-on.
抱歉。你的逻辑是什么？你觉得克里德会吃一个土豆却不知道它不是苹果，是因为法语里叫pom de terre，这说得通？是啊。好吧。印尼语里的土豆是Kentang。苹果是什么？苹果是appell。哦。好吧，法国人在他们的语言中把苹果和土豆联系在了一起。好吧。所以也许他们，我不知道。他们发现了什么。也许克里德在法国会过得很好。是啊。我想是这样。但只要他不在市场上自己去挑它们，然后敲敲它们就行。在我们离开整个克里德赌博场景之前，在12分38秒，你可以看到安吉拉坐在她的办公桌前，看着每个人并评头论足。哦。她没有参与，伙计们。她不会去赌博。她不会去打赌。不。我记得我和哈罗德谈过这件事。比如，安吉拉在办公区会待在哪里？她会看吗？你知道，她不情愿地瞥了一眼，想看看发生了什么骚动，但她不会参与。嗯，安吉拉有点爱管闲事，因为她喜欢了解正在发生的事情。
But that doesn't mean she's participating. No. She needs to know just enough to judge you, but not enough to be judged. Correct. Well, now we get to a scene that is really. really fun. Dwight has to enlist Andy's help in getting a bouncy castle, which means he has to momentarily unshun him, which leads to a great shun unshun bit. It's actually unshun, reshun. That's what he says. Yes. Unshun, reshun. And on the commentary, they talked about this little bit and they
但这并不意味着她参与其中。不。她只需要知道足够多来评判你们，但又不足以让自己被评判。没错。好吧，现在我们到了一个非常、非常有趣的场景。德怀特必须寻求安迪的帮助来弄到一个充气城堡，这意味着他必须暂时解除对他的排斥，这引出了一个很棒的“解除排斥，重新排斥”的桥段。其实是“解除排斥，重新排斥”。他就是这么说的。是的。解除排斥，重新排斥。在评论音轨里，他们谈到了这个小桥段，他们
said that Gene and Lee came up with the whole shun thing and that Rain is who physicalized it. Rain doing that hand thing up and down was just rain playing around. I loved that. I know. It really sold it. It really did. This like weird, like fake window thing that he was doing. I know.
说吉恩和李想出了整个排斥的梗，而雷恩是把它具体化的人。雷恩做那个手上下摆动的动作只是雷恩在玩闹。我喜欢那个。我知道。这真的很传神。确实如此。他做的那个奇怪的、假窗户之类的动作。我知道。
I know. So childish. Okay. So now we go back up on the roof. They have this bouncy house castle. They're, you know, this is going to be so much better than the trampoline. But then Dwight's like, do you want to test it? and Michael's like, no, no, these tests are going horrible.
我知道。太幼稚了。好吧。所以现在我们回到屋顶上。他们有这个充气城堡。他们，你知道，这会比蹦床好得多。但后来德怀特说，你想试试吗？迈克尔说，不，不，这些测试太糟糕了。
I won't do it if I keep, if we keep doing these tests. Yes. And he asked Dwight to kind of psych him up, right? And so Rain starts doing this amazing musical, like thing. It's like the thing that he does when he's pumping himself up in the stairwell before a big sales call or before a big interview. Yeah, it's the Dwight Air Guitar. Yes. Oh, it's so good.
如果我继续，如果我们继续做这些测试，我就不干了。是的。他让德怀特给他打打气，对吧？所以雷恩开始做这个神奇的音乐剧般的东西。就像他在大销售电话或大面试前在楼梯间给自己打气时做的那样。是啊，那是德怀特的空气吉他。是的。哦，太棒了。
I watched it like three times. Yeah. I loved at the end when he started to like get his like two things with his mouth. It was kind of gross when he was like, la la la. Like, yeah. Well, I noticed something, Angela. It was very windy in this scene. Did you notice that?
我看了大概三遍。是啊，我喜欢最后他开始用嘴做那两个动作的时候。当他发出“啦啦啦”的声音时，有点恶心。就像，是啊。嗯，我注意到了什么，安吉拉。这一幕风很大。你注意到了吗？
Yeah, I did. And I, their ties were like just whipping all around. Did you see that? Yeah. Well, I decided to pause at 14 minutes, 30 seconds and read the label on Steve's tie. Oh, you're crazy. And I love it. What'd you find?
是啊，我注意到了。他们的领带就像在到处乱甩。你看到了吗？是啊。嗯，我决定在14分30秒暂停，读一下史蒂夫领带上的标签。哦，你疯了。但我喜欢。你发现了什么？
It looks like it was a tie made by Gian Franco Rufini, who was an Italian clothing designer. Okay. And the reason I became sort of obsessed with this was because I recently had a conversation with Carrie Bennett, our wardrobe designer. Yeah. And she told me about how when she was designing the show, she wanted every man in the office to have a very specific tie story. she wrote a tie story for every man and she told me that this was because you know when you're designing a show where there's a bunch of men working in an office it's really hard to differentiate them it's just a bunch of people in suits and ties so she told me that when she was doing the original design for the show she got really worried that all the men were going to look alike because they were all just wearing suits or shirts and ties right so by doing this tie story this was her answer her tie story
看起来那是一条由吉安·弗兰科·鲁菲尼制作的领带，他是一位意大利服装设计师。好吧。我之所以对此有点着迷，是因为我最近和我们的服装设计师凯莉·贝内特谈过。是啊。她告诉我，当她设计这部剧时，她希望办公室里的每个男人都有一个非常具体的领带故事。她为每个男人写了一个领带故事，她告诉我这是因为，你知道，当你设计一部有很多男人在办公室工作的剧时，很难区分他们，他们只是一群穿着西装和领带的人，所以她告诉我，当她做这部剧的最初设计时，她非常担心所有的男人看起来都一样，因为他们都只是穿着西装或衬衫和领带，对吧？所以通过做这个领带故事，这就是她的答案，她的领带故事
Michael Scott was that Michael buys all of his suits at J.C. Penny, and they come with a matching tie. So he buys all his clothing as a full kit. And this tie is part of a suit kit. I looked it up. And I think this is like Michael's designer. This is Michael's stuff. That's his go-to guy at J.C. Penny's. Oh, I'm sorry, Jacques Pinet, as my Aunt Brenda used to say. Oh, is that how she says, Tracy Denny? Yeah, she'd be like, are we going to go to Tarje and then Jacques Pene? I love that. I love that.
迈克尔·斯科特的领带故事是迈克尔所有的西装都是在杰西潘尼买的，它们都配有配套的领带。所以他把所有的衣服都作为一套完整的装备购买。这条领带是西装套装的一部分。我查了一下。我觉得这就是迈克尔的设计师。这是迈克尔的东西。那是他在杰西潘尼的首选。哦，抱歉，雅克·皮内，就像我布伦达阿姨常说的那样。哦，她是那样说的吗，特蕾西·丹尼？是啊，她会说，我们要去塔吉特，然后去雅克·皮内吗？我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。
Well, I don't think you can get these guys' suits anymore because when I was trying to find them online, the only place I could find them was Etsy and eBay, people reselling them if you want a Michael Scott tie. Incidentally, something I thought was interesting, the tie maker's son is named Rimo Rafini, and he's a Billy. What's Remo doing? How do you get to be a billionaire? He is also a fashion designer, and he is the owner of this huge fashion company. In Italy. In Italy. There you go. There you go. All because they were filming on a windy day. I went down that rabbit hole. I love that. I love that. I love that. All the men have their tie story. You certainly see that, I feel like, with Andy, because he's so new england preppy i feel like his suit looks very different from the other fellas yeah um okay well and we can we can discuss more tie stories as they become relevant in future episodes i hope we
嗯，我不认为你还能买到这些家伙的西装，因为当我试图在网上找到它们时，我唯一能找到它们的地方是Etsy和eBay，人们在转售它们，如果你想要一条迈克尔·斯科特的领带的话。顺便说一句，我觉得有趣的一点是，领带制造商的儿子叫里莫·拉菲尼，他是个亿万富翁。里莫在做什么？你怎么能成为亿万富翁？他也是一位时装设计师，他是这家大型时装公司的老板。在意大利。在意大利。就是这样。就是这样。这一切都是因为他们在刮风的日子里拍摄。我钻进了那个兔子洞。我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。所有的男人都有他们的领带故事。我觉得你在安迪身上肯定能看到这一点，因为他看起来非常像新英格兰预科生，我觉得他的西装看起来和其他家伙很不一样。是啊，嗯，好吧，我们可以，我们可以在未来的剧集中讨论更多的领带故事，当它们变得相关时，我希望我们
do i'm gonna hold you to that you and carrie carry carry should send in some audio clips oh yes i'll have her do that okay or maybe we should have her on for a deep dive because she has fascinating stories. Oh, I would love that. I would love it. Okay. Well, now Dwight burst into the office, right? He tells everyone, come outside, come outside. And, you know, Michael is suffering from depression and you need to come out here. And everyone begins to ask him, you know, are we going to need a coat? And he's like, no, the weather, it's, no, it's a gorgeous day out. Come on, come on. And then he has a line. at 15 minutes one second that I absolutely love because he's like, Dwight, he's being Dwight,
会这样做，我会让你信守承诺的。你和凯莉，凯莉应该寄一些音频片段过来。哦，是的，我会让她那样做的。好的，或者也许我们应该请她来深入探讨一下，因为她有迷人的故事。哦，我很乐意。我会喜欢的。好的。好吧，现在德怀特冲进办公室，对吧？他告诉大家，出来，出来。而且，你知道，迈克尔正遭受抑郁症的困扰，你们需要出来。每个人都开始问他，你知道，我们需要穿外套吗？他说，不，天气，不，外面天气很好。来吧，来吧。然后他有一句台词，在15分01秒，我非常喜欢，因为他说，德怀特，他正在表现德怀特，
come on, come on. And then he answers Stanley and he goes, no, no, it really is. It's, it's very nice. That was so rain. It was so rain. It was so good. I loved it too. I loved it. So now everyone gets up and they go outside to see what's happening with Michael. Yeah, and we had a fan question from Caitlin, Moribito, and Brinkley Hope, who said, when the office workers go down to watch Michael demonstrate depression, some people are in the elevator and other people are coming down the stairs, but they arrive at the same time. Oh. So I guess, like, they noticed it doesn't matter if you took the stairs of the elevator. And they said, we imagine this is because they all couldn't fit in the elevator at the same time, especially because it's not a real elevator. But the question is, how would they decide who was on the elevator and who was coming down the stairs?
来吧，来吧。然后他回答斯坦利，他说，不，不，真的，天气很好。那太雷恩了。那太雷恩了。太棒了。我也很喜欢。我也很喜欢。所以现在每个人都站起来，走到外面看看迈克尔发生了什么。是啊，我们收到了凯特琳·莫里比托和布林克利·霍普的粉丝提问，他们说，当办公室员工下去看迈克尔演示抑郁症时，有些人坐电梯，有些人走楼梯，但他们同时到达。哦。所以我猜，他们注意到走楼梯还是坐电梯并不重要。他们说，我们想象这是因为他们不能同时挤进电梯，尤其是因为它不是真正的电梯。但问题是，他们是如何决定谁坐电梯，谁走楼梯的？
And which did we prefer, waiting in the elevator or being crammed in the stairwell for the start of the scene? I always like the stairwell because that elevator is small and it always made me feel a little claustrophobic. Same. I would always, if given the choice, I would vote stairs. But with the stairs, you would have to go up quite a bit and come down. So you did have to go up and down, because you'd have to tuck around behind the stair, you know, behind the corner. So now we're in the parking lot and everyone has gathered. Michael is up on the roof.
我们更喜欢哪种方式，在电梯里等，还是挤在楼梯间里开始这一幕？我总是喜欢楼梯间，因为那个电梯很小，总是让我觉得有点幽闭恐惧。我也是。如果可以选择，我总是会投票选楼梯。但走楼梯的话，你必须往上走一段，然后再下来。所以你确实必须上下走，因为你必须绕到楼梯后面，你知道，绕过拐角。所以现在我们在停车场，每个人都聚集在一起。迈克尔在屋顶上。
And this is when Michael and Dwight kind of start their show. Oh, yeah. They have it very rehearsed. Before we get into that, Jenna, I want you to know that Harold said that there was so much from all of this parking lot that they had to cut, that he had a longer version that he just loved. that really got everyone's reactions to what was happening. And he said in the DVD commentary, he was like, I hope that original longer cut that we had that you guys will all get to see it someday. And is it in the deleted scenes?
这就是迈克尔和德怀特开始他们的表演的时候。哦，是的。他们排练得非常好。在我们进入那个之前，珍娜，我想让你知道哈罗德说，所有这些停车场的内容太多了，他们不得不剪掉，他有一个他非常喜欢的更长的版本。这真的得到了每个人对正在发生的事情的反应。他在DVD评论中说，他说，我希望那个我们拥有的原始更长版本，你们所有人有一天都能看到。它在删除的场景里吗？
No, I think there's even stuff. There's some in the deleted scenes, but I think there's more that didn't even make the deleted scenes. Wow. I know. I know. Well, we had a fan question from Tess Shornick. Okay.
不，我想还有一些东西。删除的场景里有一些，但我认为还有更多甚至没有进入删除的场景。哇。我知道。我知道。好吧，我们收到了泰丝·肖尼克的粉丝提问。好的。
This is what she wrote. After 53 hours of labor and an emergency C-section that included general anesthesia, I woke up holding my firstborn daughter and the first thing I said was, Dwight, you ignorant slut. Come on. Come on. She said this was because I woke up to hearing my husband tell the nurse about how she should watch the office. So I have to know, where did that line come from?
她是这样写的。经过53小时的分娩和一次包括全身麻醉的紧急剖腹产后，我醒来时抱着我的第一个女儿，我说的第一句话是，德怀特，你这个无知的荡妇。来吧。来吧。她说这是因为我醒来时听到我丈夫告诉护士她应该看《办公室》。所以我必须知道，那句台词是从哪里来的？
Yes. Oh, my gosh, I love this line. This line for you guys rewatching is at 15 minutes, 37 seconds. Well, this was based on a skit from Saturday Night Live with Dan Aykroyd and Jane Curtin. They would do this parody of the 60 Minutes point counterpoint. And Jane Curtin played a liberal, and Dan Aykroyd played a conservative. And the way it would go is like Jane Curtin, she would present her side first. And then Dan Aykroyd would lead off with, Jane, you ignorant slut. And then he would give his counterpoint. And Jane Curtin would say, Dan, you pompous ass.
是的。哦，天哪，我喜欢这句台词。你们重看的时候，这句台词在15分37秒。嗯，这是基于丹·艾克罗伊德和简·柯廷的《周六夜现场》的一个小品。他们会做那个《60分钟》正反方辩论的模仿。简·柯廷扮演自由派，丹·艾克罗伊德扮演保守派。过程是这样的，简·柯廷先陈述她的观点。然后丹·艾克罗伊德会以“简，你这个无知的荡妇”开头。然后他会给出他的反驳观点。简·柯廷会说，“丹，你这个自大的蠢货”。
And this was this bit. So this is Michael, once again, stealing from Saturday Night Live for his little show. And also Saturday Night Live in a time when Harold Ramos knew all those folks. You have to wonder. Yes. Right. Right. I love that.
所以这就是那个桥段。所以这是迈克尔，再一次从《周六夜现场》偷东西来做他的小表演。还有《周六夜现场》在哈罗德·雷米斯认识所有那些人的时代。你不得不怀疑。是的。对吧。对吧。我喜欢那个。
I love that. I've seen that phrase on so many things. I've seen it on throw pillows, on socks, key chains, baseball hats. Yeah. It's a, it's a classic. So Michael and Dwight, yes, they're doing sort of this performance. You know, they've got it. Clearly, they have rehearsed this. And everyone starts talking in the parking lot. Like, is this real? Is it not real? It probably definitely is not real. And they start taking bets on it. Kevin gets every. one going. Yeah, Kevin says if someone gives you 10,000 to one odds on anything, you take it. And if John Mellencamp ever wins an Oscar, Kevin's going to be a very rich dude. You go Kiff. You go Kiff.
我喜欢那个。我在很多东西上都见过那句话。我在抱枕、袜子、钥匙扣、棒球帽上都见过。是啊。这是一个经典。所以迈克尔和德怀特，是的，他们正在进行某种表演。你知道，他们有。显然，他们已经排练过了。每个人都开始在停车场谈论。这是真的吗？不是真的吗？这大概率肯定不是真的。他们开始为此打赌。凯文让每个人都参与进来。是啊，凯文说如果有人在任何事情上给你一万比一的赔率，你就会接受。如果约翰·梅伦坎普赢得了奥斯卡，凯文会成为一个非常有钱的家伙。加油，基夫。加油，基夫。
Well, my favorite part of this, Angela, is when Michael realizes that the warehouse guys aren't there. Those are the ones he wants to impress the most. Yeah, he doesn't care about doing this for his co-workers upstairs. The whole point of this, and he gets so frustrated with Dwight, is that the warehouse guy see that he's on the roof. Yes. So he gets Dwight to bring all the warehouse folks out, and they start the whole thing over again. And this is when you realize it is 100% scripted. He says, Dwight, you ignorant slut, again. Yeah, Dwight does his air quotes with his fingers again.
嗯，安吉拉，我最喜欢这一部分的是当迈克尔意识到仓库的人不在那里时。那些是他最想打动的人。是啊，他不在乎为楼上的同事做这些。这一切的重点，他对比德怀特感到非常沮丧，是让仓库的人看到他在屋顶上。是的。所以他让德怀特把所有的仓库员工都带出来，他们又重新开始了整个过程。这就是你意识到它是100%照本宣科的时候。他又说了一遍，“德怀特，你这个无知的荡妇”。是啊，德怀特又用手指做了他的空气引号。
Yes, exactly. And Jim has this great talking ahead where he's like, the first performance was a little rough, but, you know, they hit their stride. And he can't wait to bring his parents tomorrow for the matinee. Yeah. It's just been great. Then we see Creed coming out of the bushes. He's zipping up his pants. Like, I guess he's just gone pee, which is so on brand for Creed that he just went over to the bushes to take a whiz with his co-workers right there.
是的，完全正确。吉姆有一个很棒的独白，他说，第一次表演有点粗糙，但是，你知道，他们进入了状态。他迫不及待地想明天带他的父母来看日场。是啊。这真是太棒了。然后我们看到克里德从灌木丛中出来。他在拉裤子拉链。就像，我猜他只是去撒尿了，这对于克里德来说太符合他的风格了，他就在同事们都在场的情况下走到灌木丛去撒尿。
Anyway, he says, guys, what's up with the bouncy castle? And they're like, what? They all run over. And this is the moment where Jim and Pam were like, oh, my God. Oh, my God. It's part of this bit. He's going to do it. Well, lady, I remember shooting the scene because it is not in the script that Creed comes
总之，他说，伙计们，充气城堡是怎么回事？他们说，什么？他们都跑了过去。这就是吉姆和帕姆觉得，哦，天哪。哦，天哪。这是这个桥段的一部分。他要做了。嗯，女士，我记得拍摄这一幕，因为剧本里没有写克里德从
around the corner zipping up his pants. And we came up with that on the day. We thought it would be really funny that Creed was taking a leak. And that's how he discovered. And that's how he discovers it. Because it was like, well, why is Creed around the corner? And like, in the moment, you realize, like, how, oh, wait, how do we justify that Creed went behind the bushes? Yeah.
拐角处走出来拉裤子拉链。我们当天想出了那个。我们认为克里德去撒尿会非常有趣。而这就是他发现的方式。而这就是他发现的方式。因为就像，嗯，为什么克里德在拐角处？而且，在那一刻，你意识到，哦，等等，我们怎么证明克里德去了灌木丛后面？是啊。
And that I, I, I, we thought that was so funny. We thought that was so Creed. So I loved that. And then I also loved that Pam tells Michael that he has to come down because she has a present for him. And he never doesn't believe her. Well, you know, Jenna, I found it interesting because when I was watching, watching this again, all I could think of is, where's Karen? Like, Jim and Pam are sort of together in this moment. They're figuring out what Michael's up to and sort of brainstorming how to help
而且我，我，我，我们认为那太有趣了。我们认为那太克里德了。所以我喜欢那个。然后我也喜欢帕姆告诉迈克尔他必须下来，因为她有礼物给他。他从不怀疑她。嗯，你知道，珍娜，我觉得很有趣，因为当我再次观看这一幕时，我所能想到的就是，凯伦在哪里？就像，吉姆和帕姆在这一刻在一起。他们正在弄清楚迈克尔在搞什么，并集思广益如何帮助
him. And where is Karen, right? Well, you are not the only person who was curious about that, Angela. We got mail on that. Oh, yeah? Kira Bailey, Rachel Ross, Maggie June, Sarah Hamilton, and Megan Womble all asked, where's Karen? Yeah. Why is Jim only? Why is Jim only? standing with Pam and talking with Pam and then we don't see Karen again until the end of the episode when she's on the other side of Jim standing behind him. Yeah. I went to the script, and there is a whole plot for Karen that is not in this episode. You know how Karen earlier in the episode, she has that line where she says, wow, I do not know the people in this office like I thought I did. Yeah, because she's losing all the bets. She's betting wrong. And she has a talking head where
他。凯伦在哪里，对吧？嗯，安吉拉，你不是唯一一个对此感到好奇的人。我们收到了关于那个的邮件。哦，是吗？基拉·贝利、瑞秋·罗斯、玛吉·琼、莎拉·汉密尔顿和梅根·沃布尔都问，凯伦在哪里？是啊。为什么吉姆只？为什么吉姆只？和帕姆站在一起，和帕姆交谈，然后直到剧集结束，当她站在吉姆的另一边站在他身后时，我们才再次看到凯伦。是啊。我看了剧本，凯伦有一个完整的剧情，但没有出现在这一集中。你知道凯伦在这一集早些时候有那句台词，她说，“哇，我不像我想象的那样了解办公室里的人。”是啊，因为她输掉了所有的赌注。她赌错了。她有一个独白，
she's like, I am like, I'm getting wiped clean here on these beds. I don't know everyone. Yes. So they had this whole plot for her where she's down in the parking lot and she's on a mission to get to know people better. So she's starting conversations with different people. She's got a little side conversation with Oscar. So I think that's why she's not standing by Jim. But those scenes are not in the deleted scenes, right?
她说，“我，我在这些赌局中被清空了。我不了解每个人。”是的。所以他们为她准备了整个剧情，她在停车场，她的任务是更好地了解人们。所以她开始和不同的人交谈。她和奥斯卡有一个小小的侧面谈话。所以我认为这就是为什么她没有站在吉姆旁边。但那些场景不在删除的场景里，对吧？
They are not. I watched the deleted scenes, and that Karen Runner is not in it. Well, one thing I did find that I thought was really fascinating, and I loved this, I'll share it with you guys, and it's about the Jim Pam parking lot sort of story. In the DVD commentary, B.J. said he talked to Greg, and Greg was talking to him about Jim and Pam in this scene, and he said, I sort of see them as a couple that had been together for a long time, and they'd had a child together. And that child is Michael. And, you know, they're no longer together. They've moved on. But like oftentimes divorced couples who have kids, when there's a
它们不在。我看了删除的场景，那个凯伦的支线不在里面。嗯，我发现了一件我觉得非常迷人的事情，我喜欢这个，我会和你们分享，它是关于吉姆和帕姆在停车场的那个故事。在DVD评论中，B.J.说他和格雷格谈过，格雷格和他谈论这一幕中的吉姆和帕姆，他说，我把他们看作是一对在一起很长时间的夫妇，他们有一个孩子。那个孩子就是迈克尔。而且，你知道，他们不再在一起了。他们已经继续前进了。但就像经常有孩子的离异夫妇一样，当他们的孩子有
crisis with their child, they work together to help their child. And they sort of have this shorthand with one another when it comes to their child. And Karen would not have known any of that history, are Michael the way they know Michael. And so it made sense that Jim and Pam would be working together to try to make sure that Michael doesn't do something really stupid. And if you think about it in that context, it makes perfect sense. And also, the fact that Pam is like, I have a present for you. That's very parent mode, right? Yeah. Come inside. I've got a treat for you. Stop doing what you're doing. I love hearing what BJ's thought process was when he was writing these scenes because something I really appreciated about them was that Pam and Jim were not laughing about this.
危机时，他们会共同努力帮助他们的孩子。当涉及到他们的孩子时，他们有一种速记法。而凯伦不会知道任何那段历史，不像他们了解迈克尔那样了解迈克尔。所以吉姆和帕姆共同努力确保迈克尔不做非常愚蠢的事情是有道理的。如果你在这种背景下思考，这完全说得通。而且，帕姆说“我有一个礼物给你”的事实。那是非常父母模式，对吧？是啊。进来。我有一个款待给你。停止你正在做的事情。我喜欢听B.J.在写这些场景时的思考过程，因为我非常欣赏他们的一点是，帕姆和吉姆并没有对此大笑。
No. This was not a joke to them. When they realized what Michael was doing, they come together very seriously to help him. This was also was not flirty. This was not a flirty moment, but instead really highlighted their bond. Yeah. And just the fact that instantly the two of them knew what Michael was up to. And it's like everything else didn't matter. It didn't matter that they had hurt feelings over Roy, over Karen, over everything that has happened between the two of them. None of that mattered. All that mattered was getting Michael off the roof safely. And that's what happens. That's what happens in real life. You put everything aside for your child. and you work together. And I loved that little piece of backstory
不。这对他们来说不是一个笑话。当他们意识到迈克尔在做什么时，他们非常认真地走到一起帮助他。这也不是调情。这不是一个调情的时刻，而是真正突出了他们的纽带。是啊。仅仅是他们俩瞬间就知道迈克尔在搞什么。就像其他一切都不重要了。他们对罗伊、对凯伦、对他们之间发生的一切感到受伤并不重要。那些都不重要。重要的是让迈克尔安全地从屋顶下来。这就是发生的。这就是现实生活中发生的。你为了你的孩子把一切都放在一边，你们共同努力。我喜欢那个小小的背景故事
between Greg and BJ. Me too. Well, it's ultimately kind of Daryl that gets Michael to come down. I mean, Daryl has this great line where he's like, no one is braver than you. You have to wake up every day and be you, Michael.
在格雷格和B.J.之间。我也是。嗯，最终是达里尔让迈克尔下来的。我的意思是，达里尔有一句很棒的台词，他说，“没有人比你更勇敢。你必须每天醒来并成为你自己，迈克尔。”
It's so brave. I couldn't do it. I couldn't do it. I mean, like, it's like, the dig that Michael doesn't understand. And he just takes it so earnestly like, thank you. And Daryl's like, you brave heart. And Michael's like, I brave heart. Yeah. And that's what got him off the roof. Daryl, Daryl believing in him got him off the roof. And the episode ends with Michael having a talking head where he says, you know, sometimes you have to do crazy things to show the danger
太勇敢了。我做不到。我做不到。我的意思是，就像，迈克尔不理解的挖苦。他只是非常认真地接受了它，“谢谢你。”达里尔说，“你这颗勇敢的心。”迈克尔说，“我这颗勇敢的心。”是啊。这就是让他从屋顶下来的原因。达里尔，达里尔相信他让他从屋顶下来了。这一集以迈克尔的一个独白结束，他说，你知道，有时你必须做疯狂的事情来展示办公室里的危险，
in an office but he saved a life today and it was his own yeah and you know he asked like is he a hero is he a hero he can't really say but yes well and then we have this tag which i love it's stanley he walks out to the parking lot and it was his car that they bashed up like stanley needs an excuse to hate michael more oh my gosh exactly now i do have to point out angela that this watermelon all over the car was clearly visible through all of the scenes while Michael was on the roof. And we had a lot of people write in and say, how did Stanley not notice this? And I can only say because what was happening on the roof was so compelling that we were all just looking up the whole time. And maybe that's why we didn't see this watermelon.
但他今天挽救了一条生命，那是他自己的。是啊，你知道他问，他是英雄吗？他是英雄吗？他不能真正说出来，但是的。嗯，然后我们有这个标签，我喜欢它，是斯坦利。他走到停车场，他们撞坏的是他的车，就像斯坦利需要一个理由来更讨厌迈克尔一样。哦，天哪，完全正确。现在我必须指出，安吉拉，当迈克尔在屋顶上时，这个西瓜在车上在所有场景中都清晰可见。我们有很多人写信说，斯坦利怎么没注意到这个？我只能说，因为屋顶上发生的事情太引人注目了，我们一直在往上看。也许这就是为什么我们没有看到这个西瓜。
Well, I wonder if that's why the deleted scene, which it's not even on the DVDs, but there was a scene where Mindy saw a busted up watermelon. And, like, she thought it was a corpse and she freaked out. Oh. There's all these deleted scenes, guys, from this episode, many that aren't even on the DVD. Speaking of deleted scenes, before we wrap up this episode, Jenna, we did get some fan questions about a scene I was in that was deleted. Courtney Klein, Alice Chan, and Maria Malick said, Angela Keyes Andy's car. Why does she do it? Is it because she despises him that much for getting Dwight temporarily fired?
嗯，我想知道这就是为什么那个删除的场景，它甚至不在DVD上，但有一个场景是明迪看到了一个破碎的西瓜。而且，就像，她以为那是一具尸体，她吓坏了。哦。伙计们，这一集有所有这些删除的场景，很多甚至不在DVD上。说到删除的场景，在我们结束这一集之前，珍娜，我们确实收到了一些关于我参与的一个被删除场景的粉丝提问。考特尼·克莱恩、爱丽丝·陈和玛丽亚·马利克说，安吉拉划了安迪的车。她为什么要这样做？是因为她因为他导致德怀特暂时被解雇而如此鄙视他吗？
how many takes did it require and did they need to fix the car each time? So yes, this is in the deleted scenes on the DVD. Listen, my character holds a grudge and Andy messed with Dwight. Angela is not going to forget it. She doesn't care if he's been to anger management. He's on her list now, lady. He's on her list. So in the way we did this scene, it was really great. Phil Shea gave me like a key chain set of keys, but the way I held it, there was this one sort of piece that stuck out, and it was basically a wax stick. And when I walk around and I do that whole line, I'm really doing that, but I'm basically drawing that line on with this sort of special wax stick. And it looks like I'm keying the car, but I'm literally just drawing a line around it.
需要拍多少次，他们每次都需要修理车吗？所以是的，这在DVD的删除场景里。听着，我的角色记仇，而安迪惹了德怀特。安吉拉不会忘记的。她不在乎他是否去过愤怒管理。他现在在她的名单上了，女士。他在她的名单上了。所以我们做这一幕的方式，真的很棒。菲尔·谢给了我一套钥匙扣，但我拿它的方式，有一块突出来，它基本上是一根蜡棒。当我走来走去并说那整句台词时，我真的在做那个，但我基本上是用这种特殊的蜡棒画那条线。看起来我在划车，但我实际上只是在它周围画了一条线。
whoa yeah i would have never imagined isn't that cool yeah and then they would just erase it then they just wipe it off oh my gosh that's so cool yeah and i and it obviously you know it's a spy shot it wasn't close up so it was really easy to sort of cheat that and sell it wow i know well guys that was safety training yes and you know not to be Debbie Downer here, but I just know how scary being that depressed can be. And I know this episode we talk a little bit about depression, but it is real. And it can really, it can really take hold of you. And I just would want anyone listening out there to know that you're not alone and that you're loved. And my nephew suffered from depression. And, um, you know, um, my nephew suffered from depression. And, um,
哇，是啊，我从来没想过。那不是很酷吗？是啊，然后他们就会擦掉它，然后他们只是把它擦掉。哦，天哪，太酷了。是啊，而且它显然，你知道，这是一个间谍镜头，它不是特写，所以很容易作弊并卖掉它。哇。我知道。嗯，伙计们，那是安全培训。是的，你知道，不是要在这里做扫兴的人，但我只是知道抑郁症有多可怕。我知道这一集我们谈论了一点关于抑郁症，但它是真实的。它真的，它真的可以控制你。我只是想让任何听的人知道你并不孤单，你是被爱的。我的侄子患有抑郁症。而且，嗯，嗯，我的侄子患有抑郁症。而且，嗯，
we lost him to it. And I'm so sorry, I didn't anticipate I'd get this emotional. But I just want you to know you're not alone and that people love you and that you are valued. And if you are suffering from depression, there are places that you can call if you feel like you cannot talk about it with your family or friends. And guys, we have the phone number for the American Foundation of Suicide Prevention. And we want to take a minute and give that to you, Angela. Yes, it's 1-800-273-8255, or you can text, talk to 741-741. And that's the American Foundation of Suicide Prevention. And, you know, this happened a few years ago in my family. And what I wouldn't give to be able to talk to my nephew and tell him how much.
我们失去了他。我很抱歉，我没想到我会变得这么情绪化。但我只是想让你知道你并不孤单，人们爱你，你是被重视的。如果你患有抑郁症，如果你觉得不能和家人或朋友谈论它，有一些地方你可以打电话。伙计们，我们有美国自杀预防基金会的电话号码。我们想花一点时间把它给你，安吉拉。是的，是1-800-273-8255，或者你可以发短信，talk到741-741。那是美国自杀预防基金会。而且，你知道，这几年前发生在我家里。如果我能和我的侄子谈谈，告诉他我们有多爱他，我愿意付出什么。
we love him. And anyway, I'm, I, I, I, I didn't mean, this was a hard episode for you to watch. It was. It was. It was. Even though there was so many wonderful things in this episode, just wonderful, funny, hilarious moments. It was a little difficult for me. And I just wanted you guys to all know that you're loved. All right, guys. We'll see you next week. Okay. Love you guys. Love you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins, and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
我们爱他。总之，我，我，我，我，我不是故意的，这一集对你来说很难看。是的。是的。是的。尽管这一集里有这么多美妙的事情，只是美妙、有趣、搞笑的时刻。对我来说有点困难。我只是想让你们都知道你们是被爱的。好了，伙计们。我们下周见。好的。爱你们，伙计们。爱你们。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·尤金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。